laughs
two hello one and all it is I Ethan
Klein
you're uh sick leader here today the
bell's ringing for me because they know
my time has come
today is um
September 20th
and it is my last day actually
my only regret is that I didn't die nine
days ago so that could have passed on 9
11.
that would have been that would have
been and then you guys could say my boss
died on 9 11. mm-hmm and what an honor
that would be to get some Stolen Valor
what a what an honor
yeah I'm gonna salute you now you guys
can remember me at the 911 memorial yeah
I'm okay I'm just a little sick thank
you guys thank you guys thank you for
this help no
thank you
thank you guys it means a lot
very brave thank you guys
[Music]
at ease how do you that's my line
at ease
thank you guys today's episode is
sponsored by stamps.com who we love
course
we love them I missed Monday because I
was sick I thought I'd be feeling better
I am feeling
better Bud
my voice is pretty scratchy and effed up
you know 600
so
but I didn't want to miss another show
you know what I mean I don't want to do
that to you guys but I don't know what's
worse listening to my voice like this or
not having another people usually
I think you sound kind of sexy when you
sound like nothing they do they're
already talking about it what does that
mean they're already talking about it
what does that mean
why just something about it you know
what about this
oh
not me baby this was mine so
um Friday was a pretty eventful though
we had a me and Dan had a massive
falling out in fact yeah I got fired
Dan is doing a George Costanza he's just
pretending nothing happened
um
golly last week was the was the
capitalism versus socialism
Peak
but I have to tell you
I'm ready to I want to talk about it
more tomorrow because I've been thinking
a lot about it great
I do I mean what well that's what
Thursday is for right that's what
Hassan's there for you can talk about it
ask grifter dog [__] more on
[__]
to be clear I'm not a capitalist I'm a
Social Democrat
okay
I think that distinction is important
because people lose their [__] mind
when I say like uh
you know I'm a capitalist they just
think that I'm like some
fat cigar smoking boot on the workers
face
grind them into dust
you know what I mean I'm a Social
Democrat [__] recognize [__]
but uh actually I I am looking forward
to tomorrow because I have been thinking
about it quite a bit okay I mean I think
it's good you know it's a good
conversation I enjoyed our conversation
I just don't like how everybody gets so
worked up afterwards and I I just stayed
off of the subreddit and the internet in
general this weekend because I just knew
I just knew that was the part that kind
of you know but I don't know if these
are real people or if they're just like
provocateurs
now they're real people of course they
are it's because the reaction is so over
the top
you know people it's a heated disc I
mean you know but I'm not saying let's
you know
let's abolish the minimum wage and and
hire children
are you sure I'm not sure about that
I'm I'm only asked I could use some
young blood around the office my only
ass my only question is this what is it
that social democracy can't achieve that
socialism can that's my question okay
let's talk about it tomorrow yes we'll
talk about it tomorrow God's sakes
okay
we will prevail though power of the
people that's right you people
Ethan I was fired for calling in sick
once that's the lead that's got to be
illegal
right
that has to be probably you know I guess
it depends on the labor laws in the
state in California that's probably
legal in Texas they're like man you
practically fired yourself boy it gets
hot in Texas you don't want to work when
you're sick you find yourself brother
actually my mom said the thing is is
like I don't think they could fire you
explicitly for doing that but if you're
in like an uh what is it at will state
which California is by the way yeah then
they could just because they can fire
you for any reason without cause so they
could just say yeah yeah we're not happy
with your performance you gotta go
and it would be obvious that they got
fired because we were sick but first
thing if they said
you're fired because you're sick you're
probably gonna well I know in California
it's very easy to get sued for that [__]
even though it's at will so sure
anyway my mom sent me this
productive pawns she said Dan is leaving
the show is this real oh it's a parody
account I think I saw production she
figured it out I'm actually proud of her
there
she's the she is a boomer with some
degree of media literacy yeah she
figured it out but productone specs
again
but people were really just thinking
like that this was the end of mine and
Dan's friendship the end of mine and
Hassan's show it was all crumbling down
not the case guys come on get a [__]
Brit this is not like if you think that
then you genuinely need to go outside
and like talk to a real person
get [__] real I mean you don't you
don't
was this just a normal conversation
um but my heart goes out to all the uh
the wage slaves I do support you guys
all the way power to the people
[Applause]
thank you
um here's the production post
that fooled my mom
yeah this [__] guy took a pledge out
of my book he's good he makes his title
so long
tomorrow will be Dan's last day of the
show throughout the past six years
been pivotal and helping create this
wonderful podcast we've unfortunately
disagreed on many recent things recently
and we've agreed as best to Part Way
never forget you Dan
you know it's full circle moment because
I believe that account came into being
from uh to me having that typo in a
tweet one time that I put out and they
immediately registered that account oh
it's a breaka ducatan you did the
production I had a tweet where I had a
typo in Productions and they helped on
that real quick
foreign
I was like Ethan should we prioritize
the stories today because you're
sounding a little rough and he's like no
I'm Going the Distance
I don't know maybe
shout out to my wage slaves out there
shout out
shut the [__] out
you guys are watching this on a break
get back to work [__] stop stealing
money did you know that taking an extra
long break is stealing money
all right let's talk about [__]
um
today we got eight passengers Colleen
and Josh updates from swoop to do and
what's the Russell Brand
um allegations
so quite a drama-filled episode I'm
trying to just get it all out of the way
so that Friday can be just Just for
Laughs
Friday fun day yes I should be baby
Friday fun day
oh [__] dude you know what I need I need
to take Tylenol
the slow descent begins darling a little
child and all the light the menorah
don't dance to tango we'll all do the
horror have you not hit the uh the quill
last night I did that's part of the
problem but not the DayQuil no I didn't
hit Dave you gotta hit that day you we
have I swear by the DayQuil I live by
the DayQuil when I'm sick we have
DayQuil I'll hit DayQuil
instead of the Tylenol because it's the
same thing right I believe it has the
same thing but then it's got some other
[__] because I can't take Ibuprofen but
I can't take that I'll grab that perks
you up I don't know what I mean I took
Nyquil two days in a row and that's a
risky proposition because that [__]
[__] me up dude it washes me out for
like a week yeah sleepy and horny that
[__] hard Oh that's oh that's too too
much information dude come on sleepy and
horny and horny when did I say that
cough medicine might be funny receiving
this PowerPoint about three years ago
I'm saving that one in the pocket what
do you like about DayQuil just makes you
feel better yeah because it it kind of
it juices you a little bit you know it
energizes you yeah
pick me up
what does that mean how yeah I don't
know what's going on I've never looked
into it too much
I forget what the name of the would it
work better if I activated it yes uh I
mean probably I'm not gonna do that
that's a joke
that's a joke YouTube I would never do
that or recommend anybody ever do that
well I don't want to hit it out the
bottle Sam
or something
there you go it has a mild stimulant
called a phenyleft God damn it these
[__] pharmacist Awards phenylephrine
phenylephrine I think I'm saying it says
nasal decongestant
is what it's listening that's the thing
is it's like it's it's the works dude it
like hits you it's like pain relief
decongestant it perks you up a little
bit it's just anti-sick see we've got
General and anti it's like a health
potion you got Tylenol get your extra
Metro fan cough's breakfast
oh sure
and then fennel phenolphthale syndrome
which is a nasal deaconessive cheers my
dudes cheers
shot if I've ever seen one love Yeah
cheers
is it I don't know I don't know [__] I'm
supposed to drink a lot of it I think
uh how much like I did I did a whole
show what does it say uh shot glass is
two ounces right yeah that's gotta be it
what does it say on the back
let me see what's a dose
um 15 milliliters
why we gotta do the different
measurements and [__] [__] 15
milliliters two ounces is a half an
ounce so that is a four times the
recommended dose oh it can't be that's
does it say it says 15 milliliters hold
on no no hold on hold on okay no adults
and children 30 milliliters every four
hours okay so that's one ounce so that's
double the normal dose yeah drink half
that thing
double means it's twice as effective
girl I think the recommended amount Earl
don't do it cheers my dudes live show
love you we'd like to drink with Ethan
people always say I want to do the eat
along when you guys do food segments
everybody get your shot glasses and bake
Cheers Cheers my dudes love you tip
he sure did there you go perfect
you healed now it's like Jagermeister
hell yeah
does them real smooth
in Jesus name amen
can I ask you guys watching does any
other host of a show do this
come out here
like this say two shots of DayQuil for
your enjoyment
name one other person who's willing to
do that can't think of it
can't oh thank you
request
I thought we were gonna do Colleen
cheating swoop
Colleen cheated on swoop Colleen
cheating swoop wait one I'm with some
[__]
I want to give Swoop to do a shout out
maybe
um featuring swoop or something calling
interviews Colleen Ballinger's ex
Colleen cheating you gotta get that
cheating in there though
cheating scandal feat swoop but it's not
featuring her feet you think it's just
throw it in there yeah well listen we're
we're capped out on characters as it is
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
Workshop this Colleen cheating scandal
featuring swoop that's pretty good dude
title language doesn't have to really
make sense you just gotta fit everything
it's just a little misleading to say
featuring uh who deserves those flowers
yeah we're featuring her content yeah
I've never misled our audience before no
we've never done the title
well it's a little too long now so uh
that's the know we got so you can remove
gross from a passenger up there because
that's granted okay touching eight
passenger uptake
inspiring all right we're good we got
the title they'll read it to me
calling cheating scandal featuring swoop
all cap swoop I know all caps played
respect on her name
all right got it uh eight passengers
update Russell Brand exposed that's a
good time
great that's a good title
no
oh my God
[Music]
you guys know I could have put on a show
I have to do it don't also hit the
Tylenol stuff
I had two here I'm not trying to die I
had two here are you putting them back
but maybe I shouldn't pick it back
because I touched them
yeah maybe not
here's my dudes
all right what are we doing
um lots of good fan art
in the subreddit following our
painting segment
yeah really good ones and actually a lot
of people took up the challenge of the
impossible angle
yeah I saw that as well
in the in the in the gallery here
fantastic
beautiful
magnificent
that's a good impossible angle shot yeah
my ass was not handsome devil ass was
not looks like it's in the style of like
gamer stuff yeah it looks like a gamer
sub Cub oh my God it does people like it
but Castle wait they wrote that I had no
idea an idea to make the crazy pose into
the stuff gamer Subs waifu cups that's
what they did that's fine that's pretty
funny talented
[Music]
well people really like this angle huh
well I I challenge them I said right
yeah yeah nobody could do it
but they they were up for it they did
the challenge
this is beautiful
this is a magnificent Earth Castle
it's inspiring of me oh that's cool this
is a beautiful hard time that's sick
yeah I like that one a lot this wanna
speak it to my soul
beautiful art
and Dayquil in fact wow
damn this is a gorgeous heart it's
beautiful it's a beautiful art huh
gorgeous
really talented artists in the audience
there always are whenever this comes out
I'm always shocked I'm kind of into this
one too
it's a beautiful type of Art in it
this person's art teacher so you know
this is high level like interpretation
yeah
[Music]
I noticed people really enjoyed trying
me very fat
well that angle was not flattering it
made you look much larger than than you
are that's what I'm saying though
there's still work to go
there's work to be done
I'm at 185 by the way
nice let's go
is
[Music]
a gorgeous hunt
oh oh speak of it to my heart
is a beautiful drawing
[Music]
come on
this is a gorgeous uh to speak of it to
my soul that is stupid cool I love that
one
oh beautiful nice you're from the French
girl
Castle beautiful
this is a beautiful land is this the one
like the Colombian yeah of that that's
right oh
33 holy [__] there's so many whoa all
right I'm gonna have to speed up no
offense enough to keep scrolling yeah
don't don't be sad if we scroll past
yours oh what the hell is this hell no
you didn't draw that oh my God are we
kidding right now the heart of the ocean
that's so awesome that's a beautiful
painting my goodness
what the hell shout out to bathroom tile
[Music]
thank you to bathroom tile I want to put
this one in my living room
that'd be super weird
[Laughter]
um
wow this one's starting to look more
accurate yeah
but that's a beautiful art I love this
art
there's one that I really love that I'm
trying to get to I apologize so damn
many of them oh that's in that artist
style as well okay like I like the
Fernando yeah tierro guys
Rest in Peace by the way right he died
that day I forgot about that that was
such a weird coincidence he died that
day I feel like we killed him
we look somehow manifested I think it
means I'm a medium perhaps probably
that's enough you reached out to you
that'd be enough oh that's enough
because it happened live too oh it was
captured live that one's cool captured
live all right this one is so special to
me and I'll tell you what I don't think
I've seen somebody draw shredder
in such a way that it really captured
like how I see him
as an angel and I feel like this is so
like yeah that's really good I just feel
like I'm I'm really looking at Shredder
and I'm really
I don't know how to describe it
you described it well yeah I know what
you mean like that's him
that's good it also makes me sad
God that's gorgeous though it's crazy it
is beautiful shout out to seven now P.S
I actually have lupus
you see that in the title oh fantastic
welcome to the club you know yesterday
I was I was scrolling the timeline and I
saw
um a post of Selena Gomez and someone
was like damn she looks great did she
get a boob job or something and they
were like no she has lupus and the
person commented back oh my God I want
lupus and I was like damn that sounds
like someone I know wait why did lupus
make her look like she had a boo some
people say that um like the medicine
from lupus can make you gain weight and
so she looks amazing and so people like
damn she get a boob job and um that
person no that's just the lupus but they
they want it really bad they wish oh man
I don't need more medicine that the
gaining weight please
please but anyway thank you seminar
I love
I love forever I miss him so much
the beautiful art huh
beautiful beautiful wow wow okay I mean
what the [__] a little disrespectful
it's a little disrespectful what can I
do I gotta I know there's a lot there's
a lot why am I dead whatever whatever
Halo wait what the description might
have a uh indication
I crack at the Zara posture Ethan is all
it says oh I don't know why you're dead
then
oh I want I love too I loved it so much
I feel like that's a really sweet one of
him too yeah
um
[Music]
used to do that too just like that
position yeah
what the [__]
who's this
I know that ain't me it looks like you
no it looks like Michigan Dude too much
wine
it looks like Mr Beast I don't know if I
see it no offense but did we need the
eight like ones not not that this is not
that this isn't a finger wow I'm just
saying there's too many there's too many
it needed to be edited
too much
and not not to disrespect it's just
there's too many you guys
and this is not me
they said they tried their best
okay well that's fine just you know me
eight votes
try harder I don't know just okay I love
that one it's beautiful
it's a beautiful art I love it so much
speak it to my soul
I could bust out in tears at any moment
nobody doesn't like us folks yeah
this uh animation is really cool someone
animated all of ours that we drew was I
going really slow
[Music]
I'm opening the animation one
oh that's a beautiful oh
it's all everybody's oh that's so whoa
that's insane yeah that's so cool that
is really sick and teach chanto
and teach Anto
that is so sick dude or do that or
here's my dude and a dudette is there a
non-gender dude I you know me dude has
transcended at this point I think so is
girl let's be honest yeah true girl is
non-gender girl I feel that I see you
girl I just called everyone like bro
dude man I don't I feel that too I just
I want to make sure you know yeah girl
is the greater
[Music]
wow amazing uh work everybody
here's some fun cab news it's got such a
idiot loser freak
he's so desperate to buy views he just
talked to Jamie Lee Man Jimmy Leary has
a million what are you doing he's buying
followers allegedly no not allegedly no
we know dead yeah it's actually not even
alleged
it's literal yeah here's the evidence
let's take a look so here's Khloe
Kardashian posting High key clout
thank you Birkin bag let me see what
she's saying one of these fabulous
prizes everything is divine you're not
but anyway anyway you have to follow all
the accounts hike key clout is following
okay there's a hundred
26.
109 right now it says no no that's her
account
Oh I thought she she tagged it in the
description or right there 126. yeah
kavkav is one of them Kev Kev is one of
them I would call that uh
what would you call that Ja Rule
oh I wouldn't necessarily say that those
are his words
yeah I don't know I mean fraud is kind
of a strong word I wouldn't call that a
false advertising
I don't know that I would say that
either I'm not willing to put go on the
record with that out of this [__] man
I'm gonna regret it I want you guys to
read my caption because all the
instructions are below hi key myself we
want to bless some people and look how
cute this is
dude she's so [__] rich like I I know
they're paying her a lot of money but
this is just humiliating she's one of
the biggest people on Instagram why the
[__] are you doing this key clout [__]
even the name is embarrassing man
like what the [__] you know it's okay to
say no to things Chloe I know you're not
like the most pop in Kardashian
but it's okay to pass on things am I
right she's not popping Kardashian she's
like I mean all the Kardashians are
popular Kardashians yeah what tear is
she I was about to ask what's here
no she's not FTR card I'd say she's like
B or C Rob is f here down in C tier of
those that is sad for right now she was
a last
year's change well what about after this
High key Cloud Club how about let's go a
plus s did she got it what that's
raising so much clout she's getting
she's getting oh well it is high key
Cloud yeah anyway so let's go to High
key clout and see all the [__] little
idiots
get paid we went to the website ten
thousand dollars right ten thousand
dollars to get a follow from high key
cloud and therefore
idiots dude morons each one of them
you're by you're buying followers people
that want a [__] Birkin bag they
don't give a [__] about you
the reason they do this is because they
don't want their followers to be from
India so it doesn't show up as fake but
it's going to show up as fake when you
post and get 100 likes idiot dumbass
losers
each one of these guys oh who's this
there he is oh hi oh my goodness it's
Ryan Kavanaugh
you idiot loser [__]
nobody likes you
just face it don't even bother buying
followers man how many likes you get on
your post it's crazy also what do you
spend your time posting weird [__] dude
you posted about the alien you [__]
freak
you posted this
the government read the caption the
caption's so funny
scientists unveil modified alien corpses
at Congressional Hearing in Mexico
exclamation
he said no this is not a new movie I'm
making no [__] you don't make moves
anymore they took that [__] part away
from you you've been making the same
movie for like six years now the only
movies you're making is with Bryce Hall
yeah
takes you five years to make it
no this is not a movie I'm making it's
no [__] the government just dropped
a bombshell by unveiling an actual alien
Corp Wiki waves new ABC and World Star
World Star reporter world star what is
this share your thoughts WTF
and then hashtag government reveal
hashtag Next Level truth yodex level
truth that's what's popping hashtag
again we didn't talk about this but
some light research is reveals how silly
this whole thing is
it's a random weirdo that keep he's done
this presentation did we not talk about
it no we never did oh
but I don't even tell you that this
ain't real
[Laughter]
y'all can't be serious with this right
now
what the [__] uh yeah
to make me lose my mind here Cav cap you
got a gate you gotta get better posts in
this 55 000 likes yeah [__] right
dumbass
High key clout
high kick High key Cloud for low clout
losers
you have no clout
and it hurts it hurts doesn't it quick
question about the alien though Ed on my
H3 bingo card I have significant life of
alien or significant evidence of alien
life is discovered is that uh does that
count no hell no that doesn't count
although cam life is a guy a TV guys
there might be something
um
um um
[Music]
James Webb Telescope oh he's doing some
deep studies of earth-like planets right
and they figured out a way to analyze
the atmosphere and if there's this
specific thing in atmosphere like
methane or so I don't know what no no
wait yeah I was just didn't they but
they didn't find that life
you know
is an output of of living life that's
like breathing living life
and so if they can find the presence of
this chemical they can pretty much
confirm that there's life there good I
want to win H3 podcast Bingo this yeah
here six days ago James Webb uh
telescope sees potential signs of alien
life in the atmosphere of a distant
goldilock world uh
uh has detected potential traces of
demethyl sulfide a chemical only known
to be created by
phytoplank phytoplankton there it is on
Earth
cool so can I Circle that on the well I
think they confirmed yet it hasn't been
confirmed cam we need follow-up studies
but it's promising hold the phone or the
President right next to that I have the
podcast tries a drastically different
format and it works can I count that for
the button
no no come on it's working you're
reaching that's not a format I want to
win
I want to win I want to win oh Ryan put
up a new video what is this
so today is Rosh Hashanah which is a
very important day
by the way oh he's like dog today's Rosh
Hashanah by the way oh and by the way
shout out to the New World Order run by
you know who
you know who's behind that dumbass loser
take those words out of your mouth bro
you're not you're not even
major shouts out to high key cloud
or you've been blessed bro you're not
been authorized to make this
what a disgrace to the Jewish people
raise here let's hear him
my preachy post the Jewish
history in the Jewish year in the Jewish
time and um really an important probably
second most important day
of each year the day that marks where we
start to reflect
uh God you're so boring also great call
to be standing right next to the
waterfall or whatever
obviously he has a lot of experience in
media right also he's like I want to
come out here and just connect with the
people on my giant patio with a water
filter [__] the city
loser 54 000 real people liked it though
oh yeah you're coming and most important
you're supposed to be wishing people a
shanato happy New Year
and the next 10 days are where we're
supposed to reflect on all the things
that's good that in the past year
we could have done differently let's
let's do that Ryan a better family
member how we could be yes your father
or better okay so we like brother a
better friend a better business partner
that's sweet better business but you
could really reflect on that one he's
like I need to be a better business
partner
bro I would never include that in my
prayer unless you really [__] your
business partners
because that's just business baby
reflect on the things that we're not as
proud of and how we could uh put them in
differently and how we should do them
differently this year showing us the
view and I just for you bro
you shouldn't originally why is he
flexing that he shouldn't show his
location like that realizing this year
the world he doesn't know how crazy
people are I'm gonna close it he's
literally the world has never been more
divided I feel if I'd showed that much
of my yard people would find where I
lived in like half a second
don't do not do that I closed it because
I want his because I respect his privacy
yeah don't try to triangulate his
position on Google Maps it's crazy
not even kidding don't I'm not saying
that like sarcastically don't do that
don't bother him man he's a good guy
he's reflecting
I he's reflecting
let's reflect Ryan
All Right Moving On
High key clout
congratulations oh he also left a
comment about me is before or after his
reflections
I believe it was before
I think
this was from
a few days ago so I still thinking of me
it was around the same time
Ryan how do you deal with that hater who
wants to warn you who wants to harm you
with comments without affecting it who
wrote that Ryan Kavanaugh
allegedly it's one that's my speculation
but it's speculating based off the fact
that we know that he's a [__] loser
idiot who would do that Ryan how do you
deal with that one hater that just you
know he's just the word he's always
bothering you and I just love you so
much I'm just a huge fan of all your
work everything you've done
[Music]
and Hang Ten to your Surfer Persona
brother
I respond I have one myself you realize
their hate comes from their own pain and
that pain causes them to think they feel
better by harming others but each time
they do it karma Stacks up
not you they are hurting it's themselves
oh I forgot to say
whoa I forgot to say oh before I leave
oh P.S I forgot to say PPS because I won
in court and he lied to his entire
audience as soon as his appeal is lost
they will hopefully recognize the harm
they are doing to others on false
statements as he will finally be I don't
know what he's talking about
like is it possible it's another set of
lawsuits that he says he said that we're
unaware of because this guy seems to be
in a lot of lawsuits I went in court and
he lied to his entire audience
about okay as soon as his appeal is lost
they will recognize oh he's saying he's
talking about the I see
we have filed an appeal on the anti-slap
so he's saying once we lose the appeal
then we will be forced to go to trial so
it's not even to recognize the harm
we're doing but yeah go to trial that's
not winning that's just
what he thinks it's he doesn't
understand that trial's a real thing
he doesn't understand the [__] black
hole that is coming for him he thinks he
wants to go to trial he doesn't
Discovery [__]
and you know what because it's about you
allegedly running a Ponzi scheme not my
words that's varieties although they
amended it right we get to investigate
all of your financials oh everything is
relevant to this because if we can prove
that you did anything close to a Ponzi
guess what
we get to investigate your collapsed uh
production company we get to investigate
your trailer Investments we get to
investigate your investment company we
get to investigate your personal
finances oh and we will thank you we
will have lawyers Around the Clock
probably get some extra hands on deck
give me a lot of documents to look
through a lot I'm angry and uh also
we're gonna compose we're gonna depose
him good it's gonna be good dude and I
like being deposed I mean I like it I
had fun last time we'll be on video it's
up to them we're gonna record the
capcoms they can record it if they want
sorry usually it's just transcribed
that sounds so fun but I like recording
it yeah I mean we've gotten a lot of
really funny deposition videos over the
year yep angry and then if if it's
relevant then you can unseal it
nice but I have a feeling it would be
relevant to something yeah it's full
deposition give them a lot of time to
reflect
I don't know though well that's that's
where the judge to decide yeah but I'm
up for it all baby you know I'm crazy as
a [__] thank you I don't give a
[__] yo
wow make it all man you have not laid it
out like that to me that is very
interesting oh about the deposition well
yeah I mean everything you just made
makes sense like of course right you
would have a right in Discovery to there
is no shot this man wants to go to
Discovery because his [__] will be
opened wide for me to step into
oh yeah brother let's go and this man
has he doesn't want me looking in there
he doesn't want anyone this is my ass
right he's too drunk to realize that
then I want you inside of me I'm gonna
get in that ass brother
I think you guys are going to be best
friends one day that's what he thought
when this started I still feel that way
and I began to slide well I thought so
too when I saw him at the um mediation
and we shook hands you're breaking him
down I feel like and I was getting more
sense and then when I went back in the
room I told the meteor let's just meet
face to face we can work this out and he
said no I think that because if you did
get him face to face he would crumble he
would melt
maybe I think it was the worst pain
in my life
I'm gonna get in that ass
he got on top and slowly inserted
himself into me okay that's me
[Music]
metaphorically doing Discovery you will
not actually yeah
would be the worst decision this man has
ever made in his life
and that's
saying something
uh yeah right and that's how that's like
the Hall of greatness yeah like the
Mount Rushmore of mistakes this was my
ass anyway shout out Kev let's reflect
let's take these days let's reflect on
how much we appreciate our sponsor
stamps.com I love our sponsors
stamps.com they're great
samsung.com has been a long time sponsor
and supporter of the show and I
absolutely love and appreciate them so
much for that and their services just oh
it's a no-brainer I mean it really is
fantastic especially with the holiday
season coming up
does your business experiencing a surge
of orders have you prepared
or do you want to be taken by surprise
you don't have to think about it dude
the Holiday Rush means more mailing
shipping for your business but I have to
mean more stress
samsung.com has been helping businesses
like yours and mine saving money for 25
years
and they're going to help you get ready
for the holiday ramp up all you need is
stamps.com premium rates for all your
postage needs let me tell you about
stamps.com tell me
spit it one
the convenience yes so easy you you they
send you a digital skill you weigh the
package boom it tells you the exact
postage
you put it on on your computer you put
it on your package or envelope and they
come get it
what you can leave it at your door you
can put in your mailbox you can put in a
Dropbox they'll come you can schedule a
pickle they will come to your house and
get it
no way but that's not even my my
favorite part is this they're getting
you fat discounts dude how much get huge
carrier discounts up to 84 off USPS and
UPS rate 84 off USPS and UPS rates and I
don't know how many of y'all ship things
regularly but the rates on shipping
lately have been nuts dude I don't know
if I've ever mentioned this but my
girlfriend Allison uses stamps.com what
and I'm really happy that she she seems
to really enjoy it she enjoys it so much
as an enterprising young capitalist
herself she runs her small business with
the help thanks to stamps.com and it's
probably so convenient for her it's so
easy she works from home the postman
comes picks up the packages they ship
off the stickers and the prints and then
whatever it's probably even probably up
to 84 percent I hear
that's a good deal you know there's a
reason stamps.com has been indispensable
for over 1 million businesses
I didn't stutter that's one
followed by six zero that's a lot of
business
get access to the USPS and UPS Services
you need right from your computer
anytime day or night there's no lies
there's no traffic there's no waiting
also I got a deal listen up
get your business ready for the holiday
Rush get started with samsung.com today
we sign up with the promo code H3
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale there's no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter the code H3
and I'm gonna say this again enter the
code H3 I wasn't sure thick thank you to
stamps I really appreciate them and I
hope you all will consider uh supporting
them
thank you
[Music]
wow
what a read thanks bro
thanks for that was good we did good um
alley-oop there yeah big assist there
uh where are we
this was pretty disturbing man
the sneako clip that was going viral is
that like a ball game or something and
these children approach them children I
mean how are these kids I don't know 12
I don't know it's hard to tell uh yeah
probably between 10 and 12 I would say
somewhere in Orange
yeah I guess probably 12 could probably
be 14. 12 to 13. they're in like the
Innocence Lost phase you think 14 maybe
yeah it feels like Middle School yeah
like
like end of middle school though eighth
grade I would say maybe ninth so anyway
listen to these children respond uh to
sneako's content
[Music]
those kids are in sixth grade I'm sorry
yeah seeing them like talk and move I
think they're younger than I was
originally thinking 11 or 12 I would say
Nico's maturity is the exact same he's
just in an older body I think he goes no
we love women oh [__] okay because I had
the wrong idea then
I thought we I thought we hated women oh
I've been listening wrong I'm a huge fan
man
[Music]
but not like transgenders oh good good
yeah no we don't love the transgenders
right sneako
that's the thing I mean I get why you
say it's disturbing it's I guess it's a
little disturbing but on the other hand
I think my impression from this was more
just embarrassment for snico like
him well confronting the fact that this
is this is your audience this is what's
going on his audience is children these
audience are children and not just that
they're children it's like listen and
maybe those kids will grow up and be
bigots and [__] or whatever but like
they're barely [__] sentient he's
like he's literally just like parroting
like well [__] women [__] women it is
like you're like there's not like any
thought going on there you know what I
mean and like my hope would be that when
they get a little older they realize how
[__] lame this is you know I hope so
but it is disturbing to see like
this influence I mean these do they walk
around school doing this [__] sure yeah
you know [__] the transgenders it's like
what
I mean there might be already some at
his school I don't know
who have who have found that part of
themselves
gays should die okay you should die
what he said that because they think
because he they that's what they think
snico wants to hear
dude that's wild
what did that kid say that little [__]
they love you bro
yeah she's like what have I done
[Applause]
so oh he said Andrew
free entertain
realize he got himself in a bubble with
the red pill content I mean I would
personally really
reverse course if I ever saw this video
about myself right well
but he had a follow-up he's actually
he's owning it
this is your boy here
their children and obviously joking
so obvious they're joking huh
I don't know I'm not joking they're no
what's the joke
they came up to you and told you what
they thought you would dab them up for
exactly you guys think it's a joke they
said [__] the women
[__] transgenders and kill all gay
people what's the joke there
I'm failing to see the joke in that
statement
this is how I was when I was 12. all
kids love Hitler
but if it sounds egregious to you blame
the rainbow flag in their classrooms
blame the media for emasculating men is
your fault for forcing an obvious agenda
not these kids boys will be boys you
know he'll all gay people boys will be
boys
kids loved Hitler it's just boys will be
kids love Hitler man
wow there's more in that album
oh there's more in that album I'm sorry
open it again
ah
thank you kids cutting their wieners off
like hasanabe what
I know that's kids making edgy jokes
like snico what the [__] the [__] does
that mean what
it doesn't mean anything
but but first of all Twitter gay people
let's say that's not necessarily an edgy
joke that's just hate speech
that's like violent freak [__] delete me
from this conversation dude it's just a
joke bro kill all gay people it's not
funny about that
boys will be boys they're in sneako
youth
[Music]
um snico continues
udahar
thank you moodlehar for speaking truth
to power not really power but just
speaking truth
uh if this was my family's and I met
them like this I put a book in my head
okay I don't condone that just in case
the YouTube people are watching
I definitely would never say anybody to
do that that's inappropriate like Dunkin
Donuts saniko said why can't they
realize that kids will never resonate
with fat soy boys dude
what about the fat soy boy kids
oh we got that corner market dude there
you go cornered to me to Heart
when will you understand
oh he's such a [__] bag
he's so lost in the sauce man
one day he's gonna wake up lonely
broke
and totally lost
his fans will have grown up
he's gonna wake up in a studio apartment
at the age of 45.
charity Corner dirty carpet
cigarette Ash everywhere girlfriend
didn't love her in the shower right no
no no Nico's alone in the bedroom he's
nobody's there you think no one's there
no nobody's there the only people wow
she left with you can't even get cooked
right dude the only people that have sex
with him is prostitutes
she goes too frequently right
I thought there's anything wrong with
that I'm just painting a picture right
he's probably picked up drinking as a
habit probably started hit you know
makes him uncomfortable but he clears
half a ball of vodka every night and
honestly it started to become more like
the other night he finished a whole
bottle wow he lost a lot of hair too
starting earlier in the day too yeah
like on the back of the head and you
know what he has on the TV old YouTube
videos of him talking to Andrew Tate
just to remember the good times
reminiscing
um just kind of vacillating between
sadness and anger he doesn't have it
anymore and he'll be like he'll be like
when will kids understand
they're not going to listen to Fat soy
boys
I'm drunk and he's the best boys like me
who pulled out their Glock and
threatened
penguin zero
wait what remember that one time when he
pulled out his uh [__] what was it
called oh and then uh Charlie pulled out
his bigger gun in his video
right
you know what he probably goes to the
bar near the school
goes out there when the buses come by
eyeballs the
the girls it's very it makes them all
very uncomfortable and they all talk
about how creepy is or that they hope he
never tries to talk to them in person in
fact the guards at the school have even
been warned about him
they've told the cards the principal the
teachers that this man makes us very
uncomfortable can you please keep an eye
on them and they do they do keep an eye
about you
and so does the state
because you've been on the sex Defender
registry for a while now he's been on
the sex offender emergency for a while
now and he doesn't he's not gonna move
because he can't stomach going to
another family and telling him having to
do that humiliating Walk of Shame around
the neighborhood again you know
it doesn't matter that you think having
sex with a 15 year old isn't a crime it
is a crime yeah your opinion doesn't
matter in this case this is all um
hypothetical yeah this is speculative
we're just kind of projecting into the
future just telling a story this isn't
based on reality right
this dude has like 10 different
flashlights
and he'd buy more but he can't afford it
are any of them real rare rare finds
one of them is the uh chandelier from
Beauty and the Beauty and the Beast yeah
one of them's Thomas the the train
[Music]
ah he's gonna be fine I'm sure of it
it's Nico you're gonna do just fine he's
on a good path he is he's on a good he's
on a good path
he's doing really good I'm happy for him
[Music]
people
nothing makes me feel better than
talking to 10 year olds and then going
what have I done yeah
I'm happy about that actually he's good
he's good oh 10 year old fan right away
yo Mitt Romney
is not
usually call based
but I oh let's not forget this tweet man
this [__] actually put this out
here
yo that's some crazy [__] right now
I made a confession in my new video
oh I forgot about the whole cutie stand
thing
okay
it's okay I go to the gym
don't worry about it
I love my cuties
I've got it on VHS DVD and Blu-ray VHS
yeah you got it all in this collector
wow I watch cuties sometimes there's a
special quality to cuties on VHS you
don't get from Blu-ray
like the
messed up tracking kind of it's lower
quality so you can use your imagination
more he's got the laser disc he's got
the betamax that's kind of [__] what I
said but it's him saying that not me now
you say that
all right let's move on Mitt Romney's
based his AF dude
he's a billionaire right or close to
he's a billionaire yes
and like the worst way too like
investment
funds [__] right uh
uh I think it's a little more
complicated than that he's sort of uh a
big criticism of him I remember when he
was running against Obama was that uh
Bain Capital is the name of the firm
that he founded Bane yeah just yo your
your investment firm is named after a
Batman villain and uh
and I believe uh they specialized in
like liquidating companies so they're
they're kind of like a vulture
capitalist organization even worse
right so yeah not not with all that
being said though
even our boy
[Music]
vulture capitalist Mitt Romney
is out here with some good ass takes
listen to him I love this
I just don't think that we need another
person in their 80s I'm a little long
obtooth already we don't need more like
me but I do think that the times we're
living in redemand the Next Generation
to step up and and express their point
of view and to make the decisions that
will shape our American politics over
the coming century and just having a
bunch of guys that were around the Baby
Boomers who are around in the post-war
era we're not the right ones to be
making the decisions for tomorrow well
so well said I do agree with everything
he just said
enough to see somebody
in that world saying it you know like
you know you got to plant a tree for the
Next Generation type of [__] man or you
know Mitch McConnell's sitting there
with half a functioning brain
I'm out trying to lead yeah
Madness
so shut up men we love you for that
also Jordan Peterson is out here with
some deep thoughts
co-signed by Elon Musk really
interesting stuff here uh Jordan tweeted
out
the PhD in Psychology deep thinker one
of the greatest thinkers of our time
some say
hate speech is an inevitably defined by
those who hate speech
Elon Musk had touche touche
thank you
it's like a
Jaden Smith tweet kind of yeah it so is
yeah
he's always defining hate speech here
too so oh my God can we talk about like
the political and economic state of the
world yes we should have listened to
Jaden
should I listen to Jaden it's also it's
like all hate speech so he's saying all
hate speech is legit
all hate speech is Dub
wait what are you saying
hate speech is defined by those who hate
speech therefore hate speech before has
been judged by people who hate speech is
dope and Fire free speech fire
dope [__] like kill all gays
is that dope hate speech do you not
follow
it sounds like Love's got you I I yeah
it's a little too advanced for my he's
my brain I think no hate speech is HP he
says all hate speeches quit it's okay
yeah right he has no problem with hate
speech because only people that hate
hate speech are those that hate speech
you know the people who Define hate
speech
hate speech
okay then it means the same thing still
right hate speech is only defined by
people that hate
Free Speech right like for example
killing all gay people right which is
just a joke is one of seeing Nico's fans
said so people that don't like people
saying
kill all gay people maybe it is deep
yeah no I mean it's it's twisting
twisting my brain
touche my brother
touche here's my dude
it's just touche
what did
okay
he's literally defining hate speech in
this tweet oh whoa whoa how many layers
deep does this go because he's saying
hate speech is as defined people who
hates me dude what the [__] oh
by your logic bro by your own logic bro
there's a peek into your futures uh
sneako six years old honk if you love
cuties
okay wow yeah that is true you know this
how how stained his carpet is
it's bad it's a crazy thing to put on a
school bus that's a real crazy thing to
put on a school bus speaker would do
that he didn't do that yeah he did it he
does not age well wow no
he's got a lot of still doing the
eyebrow slip
away
sickness bro it's very end that's
Timeless [__] dope [__] brother I
[__] love that [__]
anyway
Jamie Lee was on that how we podcast it
happened you guys wow
he made it he really made it
I'm so happy man it happened so fast
like a whirlwind Romance
in love one minute gone the next
just like Casablanca
just wasn't meant to be star-crossed
lovers in the truest sense of the word
we'll always have pairs we'll always
have the podcast Jimmy said
yeah dude and also it's getting good
views
like better than like for example JoJo
who what who 42 000 Jimmy Lee 115 000
and one day that is crazy especially
because JoJo was talking about the
Colleen stuff yeah bro yeah dude and we
were talking about I thought more people
go watch it right Joe he has the most
views since basically Bill Burr
he's a funny guy another Mark Norman has
a little more but Joe Jimmy's gonna pass
it yeah go ahead
I'm gonna say another fellow comedian
Bill burrow oh Dr Mike was on his show
it only got out 77 000. what an idiot
loser
I don't know people like chalk their mic
I guess I like him he's a nice guy you
do
he sucker punched Ian it's hard to get
past that
that being said I mean you know he's hot
so he's got that going for him
you know that carries a lot of weight it
does he's hot as [__] dude are y'all
seeing him shirtless he's so sexy so
there's that to consider
which I didn't until now
but um anyway Jimmy's crushing it man no
you know what is Jimmy having a moment
like a real moment because now maybe
what will happen is other oh dude listen
to this [__] all right Jimmy
hits me up
and says do you want Carrot Top on your
show
and he sends me a picture of him with
Carrot Top and I'm thinking there's no
damn way he can get me Carrot Top not
that I think that Carrot Top is like a
super hard Gat I mean peace and love I
like Carrot Top
I like him I always laugh when I see his
bits man
but I'm like Jimmy doesn't he can't get
me in buddy right so I said yes Jimmy I
want Carrot Top just to see if he could
do it
he sent us a number
I hate you not
Zach texted it today right Zach he's
gonna put me in touch with his PR leader
are we comfortable saying that was
carrot Top's personal number he
responded to you immediately yeah
is that Jimmy's second foe well I said
have him send him a blank photo with the
date I just I don't think it's like
that hard of a get you know and the way
that Jimmy met him like dude carrots not
giving his personal number out I
wouldn't put down the ways of the Dr
wiener man yeah I was saying he's he's
too powerful now because the combination
of a million followers plus being on
Howie's podcast I feel like that's gonna
get him a lot of interviews that's the
way he speaks it he just like he
presents himself the way that he is so
famous yeah he's so good he's really
good
he believes the world it's not alive you
believe it another Costanza quote he's
the definition of fake he told how he
had a TV show yeah a TV show he's got a
movie coming up he's got two movies oh
yeah he's doing everything
kind of wrong it's not alive you believe
it
you know some people say Aristotle is a
good thinker I think Costanza is the
best thing
can't stand you
um but I actually I'd have carrot on the
show I like carrot I think he's funny
man people people give him a hard time
because he does props but he's he's
funny
yup you know I think Karen's ready to
have a second
second uh chairman of the board oh yeah
part two
talking about carrot yeah he deserves
another shot at chairman of the board
carrot had uh
carrot was a participant in one of my
favorite episodes of Reno 9-1-1 do you
remember did you used to watch that show
yeah I did but I didn't see the carrot
Club yeah he I think he was they were he
murdered somebody in a hotel or
something he's so funny isn't it he was
pretty funny yeah
I don't know why people give him such a
bad rap and he's he's funny dude
anti-gen Ginger discrimination
so I'm like okay let's bring carrot on
the show [__] you know I mean if Jimmy's
gonna get the hook up
this is it eh yeah Arena 911 and that's
Peak was a funny show dude so good it's
way ahead of its time so funny man
oh yeah there you go
there he is
so
I thought it was interesting but yeah I
mean Jimmy you know how it works one
thing happens and then Steve Rossi
messages like Bobby Lee
PR people and then they go oh he was on
H3 he was on Howie
okay we need a guest next week Jimmy Lee
might start making the rounds
and I swear to God nothing would make me
happier than to see that
it's like only I'm Dr Frankenstein
and he is my Frank he's my monster
it's alive
he's viral comedian jamilian I'm like
the dude I'm like the scientist in Wuhan
who invented covid that's hotly debated
that's hotly debated sure we don't know
if that actually happened let me leave
the monster
no I love Jimmy
so let's let's look at some of the
highlights I actually thought it was
quite good the interview Jimmy was good
he wouldn't he didn't push too hard
it was like a nice mix between James
Weiner and Jimmy Lee
let's take a look
this type of comedy and people Jaclyn is
it yes and Jackman people that are young
or are loving me which I was surprised
like I have a lot of young fans that
like this and I'm surprised how because
I'm an older guy and I grew up with Don
Rickles and Rodney Dangerfield and you
and red fox that's the comedy I like and
that's what I do and it seems to be
getting accepted in this politically
correct culture for some you just put
Rodney Dangerfield red fox and Howie
Mandel he grew up watching them yeah
let's go back to that Jimmy grew up
watching Howie he grew up watching Howie
I mean he's a 90s kid he's a big act but
he loved Bobby's World Bobby's was yeah
he was right there man Eddie Murphy grew
up watching him yeah after after school
every day Jimmy just sitting
cross-legged on the floor of the uh of
the playroom
I love how it goes the young people love
my act and then also he talks about how
people are throwing Tomatoes at him
Non-Stop
[Music]
that's actually really funny when he
gets into that the people do love him
though that's he's like a whole Paradox
fan
Jimmy is a whole Paradox of a human
being he's one of a kind
oh and wow oh [__] Yeah medium no my one
son is reserved like my wife my wife's
Asian she's quiet and the other one's a
little nutty like me because Asian and
quiet yeah
even when you're not doing your stuff
you know you're saying things that could
get you in trouble but when I think
about my wife I get a little hungry you
know because she's an even
[Music]
even when you're not doing your stick
you know you're saying things that could
get you in trouble but when I think
about my wife I do I get a little hungry
you know because she's Asian
fantastic
um okay
when that joke makes everyone in the
room like go like okay there was one
with the craziest crickets was that the
gay one which one was that that was the
gay one yes dude you all gotta see this
dude this is this is s tier contest
you called her on the carpet I did but
wouldn't you be ashamed of your child if
they did that yeah absolutely what
should you as a as a fellow especially I
have sons yeah so I wouldn't want them
to do that you wouldn't want them to do
what what you said blow jobs yeah
the guys well there's nothing wrong with
that
you know I took one of my friends how
are we on a vacation everybody came it
was good oh he just fell right back on
vacation he saved it though he saved it
the laughter in the in the back room oh
Howie every time we fly we sit in the
coffee room he's a nice guy
he's a good guy
I took him to London Howie to find out
to see Big Ben he found out it was a
Glock he got pissed and left he's not
even talking to me now oh he's pissed we
haven't even established who he is yeah
who's he in this scenario he starts
playing the hits you know yeah but I
love it because it's like what do you
say
in the face of such
such words and there's they're just
they're rendered speechless Jacqueline
you know you know my ass doctor Dr bend
over
why was my comment about the [__]
inappropriate but now you know my doctor
Dr bend over I don't he's got brown
fingernails I don't go back weird
it's okay Jacqueline he took 50 percent
lovely yeah
he focuses in on somebody yeah isn't
that right to live he finds a prey I
love that I've been calling Olivia live
ever since Jimmy was here last week it
is pretty good and I told Howie I'm
doing everything half-ass
I got problems sounds like I got a
shitty attitude
nothing's easy my dentist is a beaut I
said doc I got yellow teeth he said go
I'm gonna wear a brown necktie
yeah I don't get that one
and I had braces I had the porcelain
ones and I got yellow rubber bands
because I thought it would make my teeth
look whiter
it did not it did not I thought I was
smart I think it's smart oh it might
just make them look more yellow too it
did yeah there are a lot of uh photos of
me smirking instead of smoking my
brother
my doctor's know better he told me in
six cases of BD in last week but he's
all right now I gave himself a shot of
penicillin you know my doctor Dr Vinnie
boombots how he knows him that's how he
can't even look at Rodney
I was like what did Ethan get me into
but he said it was amazing he liked it
okay okay
I'm glad he had a good time
they both did by the end they kept
saying they were like calling each other
family well no Jimmy was no how he was
saying it back he was like you're like
Uncle Jim the first part he's like he's
like we're family now
let's check out some more highlights I
could be seen and be more mainstream
known right now I'm H3 branded I'm not
mainstream branded oh by the way by the
way whoa I mean hold on all right Howie
don't put this on me you made this
Choice look at the title
Jimmy Lee from Ethan Klein's H3 podcast
crosses line
hey
he does not work for me I got nothing to
do with nobody I don't know nothing
about nobody Howie
isn't that funny uh
you got to put my name and the podcast
what did you put my address to him my
P.O box
where to send the suits
three is trying to do Ethan called me
and said book and I would do anything
for Ethan I love you I always in the
world for you
wow I love Howard I love Howard man he's
the [__] best
I hope we didn't burn a big favor from
Jimmy
no he's happy he's happy and the
episode's doing really well I know I
think it's a thumb that's true
um man it's so cool what happened
between me and Howie that were such
tight dogs now
who thought him stalking in the park
stalking me in the parking lot of uh
Malibu outdoor mall would result in a
beautiful friendship like this I did not
I'll take my thanks
in the form of a sentence because you
from you why you talked me into I talked
you in dude I don't know you wanted
nothing to do with Howie Mandel not
because and I said I just Howie is it
comedy Legend
he's very very very funny America's
Uncle see I knew people don't know that
he's actually he's funny the thing is I
um I thought he was just too vanilla and
it'd be boring that's all nothing gets
him personally yeah no I got it but I
was dead wrong
so thank you Dan it's true I do owe you
for talking to that
oh it's nothing oh I feel like the
prolapse definitely helped his case
you know as far that was after not after
our interview with him though
the
uh the prolapse was after Ethan went on
his show the first time
you came on our show for the first time
after the prolapse yeah yeah yeah yeah
but we contacted him pre-prolabs you
were on his show first yes
looks was great that was a good show
Ethan gave me I'm not gonna pan up to it
but Ethan gave me that painting right
there you see that painting up there
what is that
the pro Labs
no actually no that's the first person
that looked at that and said prolapse
yeah I guess he's a doctor yeah
I mean he's in dentistry how many
prolapse have you seen
scene one you've seen them all oh I love
this I watch it Jacqueline I watched it
I was hysterical I watched it before the
live show oh I have another Scandal
that's going on that maybe we can have
his take on okay and then um talking
about his music career
really big stuff here
I'm gonna accomplish singer songwriter
accomplished pull up pull up uh kid
Vegas Jimmy Lee pull up the video oh kid
kid Vegas Jimmy Lee yeah before Jersey
Outlaw he's changed from kid Vegas no
kid Vegas is a song I wrote this and you
want to watch the music can I play it
and uh that's it right there watch it
watch that okay this whole song and we
did a music video okay this was on radio
long time just before I did comedy down
[Music]
I
checked the episode it didn't get
claimed okay fantastic
[Music]
so cute oh he's listening so intensely
but yeah yeah that's a meme template for
sure oh this is [__] fire man you
guys go go ahead and just meme the [__]
out of it another funny and weird thing
about Jimmy is he is it a very
very talented piano player a musician
dude yeah no yeah he's he he is a
musician he's Billy Joel
I need to see him sing live when I heard
it more like yeah intimately it
definitely sounds like him he calls me
all the time like just cold calls me and
starts playing the piano
oh he starts what he starts like playing
the piano and starts doing like playing
like Springsteen songs and [__] like
dude he's such an interesting guy man I
don't know what to say Jimmy is just an
Endless Enigma his dream is to go to a
piano bar with me oh and I keep telling
him no I think he used to open for
you know no I think
just said his name how do I forget it
Billy Joel should open for Jimmy Lee at
Madison Garden wow Billy Joel should
open for Jimmy yeah yeah right step
aside
[Music]
Vegas so
okay that's kind of awesome kid Vegas
he's kid Vegas is this another
kind of persona of his like how Zach has
like Lou and all those I don't know but
he's kidding every time we fly we sit in
the cocktail yep so go watch it I mean
the whole thing is pretty fun and shout
out to Howie for doing that I'm truly uh
I truly love this collaboration there
it's been really fun they're the last
time stamp in there I just like there's
two moments where he keeps asking to get
a picture with Howie he's like it's for
social media it's for the social media
oh boy
I found it so amusing exactly
yeah she's Asian and she likes to drink
that's two kinds of I can't drive
who's that behind the glass
Kyle and and uh good to see you back in
men's clothes you look good it's been a
while
still do trick with the monkey yeah he's
a fan of the show by the way cool dude
shout out he's the one that hooked up
with that pillow I think oh oh nice
okay you still do a trick with the horse
yeah with Trixie
okay I saw you in Vegas last year you
missed it do it hit it I saw you in
Vegas last year
do you know the hookers in Vegas drop it
drape it and droop it in your case they
droop it
you didn't know that now yeah I was with
awkwardly said I dropped my bench he
dropped their price
hookers in New York they meet you greet
you and eat you it's a little different
over there
you follow me no
no is he saying he's what does he mean
by that what what did they see that they
lowered the price his penis being small
they felt bad for him because if they
lowered the price that would imply that
they liked it more
uh that's one way you can interpret it
but I I think I'm gonna cut you a deal
so you come back right I think it's more
just they felt bad
it's like easier the more expensive it
is yeah I suppose that is I think it's
just so small that it was just so
pathetic that they felt bad and they
gave a steep discount yeah that's my
read I think you need to watch the
Rodney Dangerfield Joe compilation that
he stole it from the full uh we don't
talk about that yeah
do you follow me no you don't follow me
yes yes you follow me yes follow me I'll
call the cops I don't even know you
I got problems
I got two kids in private school they
won't even tell me where it is
they told the kid to form a double line
it went had cocaine
cocaine what
happened
[Laughter]
I'll tell you it's it's it's rough out
there it's a rough world too all right
siamese twins can't even make ends meet
you want to do a closer you want to like
the podcast is kind of yo that sandwich
slap the heart is all [__] dude yeah
let's play some rocks that let me just
[__] my mouth dude I just I just
tagged on the [__] of that sandwich
to build to craft it that's all right
damn it was so good did you get the same
thing as me nah I got the bacon chicken
picking chicken
salad I don't know it's just good I just
eat it
they say it's all about the bread but I
have to say I also like what's in it's
about what's in between the bread as
well I agree breakfast it needs to have
both
oh it's a lot of sandwich
bread comps Dan
Fred comps
um bread comp what the [__]
you okay
I'm gonna do a closure I want to say uh
to Howie Mandel and his daughter
you made a little guy from New Jersey
feel a little bit important I love you
both for believing in me and having me
on today well I can't even do enough I
love you guys well we love you
um you are really really interesting I I
want you to get everything that you want
I want you also to be careful I want you
to be careful because there's somebody I
want you to be nice be a nice guy no but
I you know the internet is a scary place
right now and people are really
sensitive and I I want you to you know
just have fun be happy be healthy he's
histrionic Howie don't push and I want
to thank uh where's the picture bar
coming up yeah it's like right when they
go to cars
that was fun it was my time and uh also
for putting a lot of our staff to work I
want to thank Kyle and Jeremy who just
have confused looks on their face like
uh we've never had to work this hard
yeah
you feel baby
doing all right yourself I spoke to the
brothers You're gonna be all right
you'll be here oh God nothing in the
truck in about an hour and a half with
Leroy you know Deacon Leroy he's coming
to pick you up he doesn't know when to
press that button he doesn't push the
button well he's waiting he wants to
know when the punchline was I don't
think was there a punch line on there
okay now
my husband Jacqueline I'm just fast
forward
love you guys and people feel I'm part
of the family now you are you're like my
uncle oh I do want to um
now again Howie is 67 I think and he
said Jimmy is like his Uncle yeah
so you guys do the math on that one yeah
he's 67. there before Saturday or no no
well it'll air before a Saturday okay no
I have a comedy TV shoot on the 16th all
around Hollywood well is there somewhere
where they can go find like your comedy
stuff or yeah they can go too
jamesweener.com
no how we lead the Jersey Outlaw at
Natasha I had some games free asking
okay on that note
wait so where's the picture yes this
morning I thought I was being following
you I just passed it yeah
this is killing me
let me re-click the
let me record okay you just burped up
somehow yeah I I had some gas this
morning I thought I was being followed
by two Arabs what I'm all right now but
bro that's not a good one we I tried to
tell him so many times
it doesn't really make sense that's one
of that's probably one of the most
offensive no because Arabs smell like
farts oh
Jesus Christ it's crazy they're
he's got to stop with
I've tried I've tried oh my gosh we've
tried to have interventions be like dude
cut this one don't do that one
it's my favorite one
but he brought it back man he almost
made it through but then he just
couldn't resist
but thanks for asking no laughter from
that one
where's the picture one dude it's audio
just play keep playing it oh
course
Danny to take a picture with me in the
Middle with that yeah that's viral thank
you I really
anyway go watch it guys it's good
good after you watch this entire podcast
though of course
and any other a podcast of mine that you
haven't watched every second of
then you can go
um you heard from Carrot Tops published
this app I did go ahead uh they reached
out and uh we're gonna we're gonna work
on getting a date uh possibly in October
is he does carrot want to come in yes it
would be impressive oh my God because
he's Mr Vegas he's gonna fly out here
big they gave me a date that won't work
because it's on the weekend but we're
we're gonna get Carrot Top in studio we
get Carrot Top in studio I feel like
Jimmy has a right to be there
yeah
he's gonna make you pay to fly Dan
Karen's coming
wait it's an oil joke yeah cause you're
saying Arabs smell like gas
okay interrupt but he said fart he says
okay
that's
not as bad as saying they smell like
farts but it's still bad that's funny
but you really have to think deep to
pick that up yeah
all right thank you moving on this one
kind of tickled me a little bit I gotta
be honest
I saw I've seen this on tick tock
how often do you guys think about the
Roman Empire
how often Dan genuinely
how often like be honest you're gonna
get arrested for this go ahead
some we were talking about it yesterday
and I thought about it I would say
probably two to three times a week
so sick is that the best question ever
yeah two to three how do you think about
it that much
I mean you know you come to it from all
sorts of different angles wow it's like
you know it's an important turning point
in history
wow I feel like in my brain I get like a
flash of the Coliseum frequently like
it's a familiar image in my mind yeah I
say every day honestly every day I see
the Coliseum every day in my brain I
don't know it could be so many American
Aesthetics are like based off that
neoclassical Roman Empire do you think
about the Roman Empire cam
what's that okay multiple times a week
I'd say I don't know wow eat it
I don't like once every six months or
something I don't know not often that's
what that's kind of what I where I was I
was thinking maybe once or twice a month
but what about since Elon and Mark have
been talking about their fight I've been
thinking a lot about the Roman Empire
because I've just been like wow imagine
if this was back in the day and Facebook
was back in the day oh and we settled
there and they went and we settled I
watched like documentaries at least once
a week
how much is there to learn dude I my my
for you patient stuff it comes up every
now and then give me one well give me
one fun fact about the Roman Empire like
they built their roads super far and
they still last and for example in like
Pompeii they built the roads with step
stones in them so when the sewage like
flowed you can step on the stepsons that
is a fun fact yeah but also between the
step Stones they made it so that the
wheels on the carriage can go between
the step stones
Zach how many times do you think about
the Roman Empire same with same as the
union answer uh just once every six
months yeah
I don't know about two or three times a
week you gotta step it up dude
I mean you come to it from all kinds of
angles it has had a lasting cultural
impact can we do Western Civilization as
we as we do in a week of shows starting
tomorrow or today let's try to tally
every time we mentioned anything related
to the Roman Empire well it doesn't come
up on the show very often well we talk
here for four or five and that wasn't
the question if the question is how
often do I talk about the Roman Empire
that's a very different answer so in
your mind you're going through yeah all
the finer points of History
that's interesting though isn't that
funny because it's not just history bro
we're we're still living in it that's
the thing true you got to expand your
mind bro so important
the Romans have done it all it's so so
important you guys
so so so so so important well there you
go I'm surprised by some of your answers
that's very cool
the joke I guess was that uh when girls
ask their boyfriend
they were always like I think about it
and then the ladies are always like I
don't what what but Olivia is is uh with
the Roman Empire only because I think
really only because I've Elon Musk has
been pushed in my face so frequently
Gladiator the Gladiator of Elon and I
just have that image so it might just be
extra pertinent right now but and
Sam what is the Roman Empire and how
often do you think about it ocean out
there
one girl day
Sam game
you gave me my sandwich was that what
happened
she thinks about the it's the Greeks or
probably the Greeks that's okay fan I
think what like salad dressing
yeah
feta cheese all right let's move on God
damn it
all right we've been going 2 30. oh what
we want to go in an hour and a half it
feels like hella longer
well that's good we have plenty of time
left
foreign
so we have Russell Brand we've got
[Music]
um
eight passengers and we've got oh God Dr
Kenny is good
but that we got to do swoop first
all right let's just start with swoop
there it is all right there it is yeah
this is a crazy one I'm gonna go to the
bathroom Okay and then we can get into
it that's okay
all right I'm gonna go to the bathroom
and then we'll get right into the show
dog be right back that's totally chill
dog
Ethan kind of talks like this today it's
kind of chill dog
um
listen I knew I was gonna get judged
hard for that Roman thing when I saw
that that was in the dark but I gotta be
honest with you folks hey man that's
what makes the show interesting right
and I'm glad to hear I wasn't alone
thank you for backing me up cam oh I
mean I'm a history nerd too you know
excuse the thing I'm just big history
nerd and when you read about history
it's inescapable you know I never think
about the Holy Roman Empire though [__]
[__] them losers l
[__] Crusades [__] that [__]
uh let's see I saw a super chat a minute
ago
they like made it so just a slight
degree down right for months much much
the water flows nicely I've been seeing
a lot of stoic philosophy on the uprise
too online and online circles For Better
or Worse the last great Roman Empire as
the Emperor as he's called it's awesome
meditations about it and they had pipes
in their house isn't that crazy that
yeah faucets absolutely thousand like
how a long time ago were we talking
about the Roman Empire we do and uh
Ethan asked your opinion and you weren't
here so maybe you can chime in now I
actually do think about it kind of often
thank you Sam I
I've gotten student for four or five
years there you go it's that Catholic
upbringing no I think that it's cool I
wanted to get like ancient Rome like
tattoos once I never did but I don't
know I kind of do think about it love
that miss her you want to get matching
the ancient Roman tattoos
yeah you and me yeah yeah like the
Coliseum or something let's get the
glasses so cool on our hips it's so cool
um why can't I [__] find these super
chats Ethan was right the system sucks
you're doing great Jan not I played
where they're supposed to be here I got
you I'll cover you I played fortnite
last night with Ian and Dan
and we did for the first time in like a
year
Ian was amazing Dan was good I was
horrible
I only got a good not an amazing I got I
mean juicing was kind of amazing if I'm
being honest really he was carrying us
yeah he was he was caring I kind of you
it's an issue with that but dude why
won't it show me the [__] super trash
aqueducts they actually when it was too
deep they built one Aqueduct and they
will build another set of it on top
isn't that sick it is super sick yeah
yeah they stacked them up it's awesome
yeah it's sick
when do you think uh the Roman Empire
fell I don't know a couple couple years
ago
a couple years ago it never fell it
never felt last Christmas yeah well
actually if you saw the new Indiana
Jones movie I didn't
there is a timepiece that goes back in
time is it a Rolex no it's Archimedes uh
Archimedes Rolex yeah a gold president
I think my you know what my plugin broke
it's not recording the super chats
anymore that's a problem yeah unplug it
and plug it back in [__] dude yeah it's
over take us out
see you tomorrow short up today let's go
my ex-best friend is my Roman Empire sad
face
I don't know if I follow they fell
mizamo BB
what is dzd what is that currency these
nuts I know
Algerian dinar okay
shout out Algeria shout out Algerian
watcher
that's pretty cool
shout out
can we get a Roman Empire T PowerPoint
Olivia maybe like yeah there's plenty of
it yeah I think the interpersonal
relationships on that will go crazy the
one that Julius Caesar tea kaikili is
the resilience and Brutus there was
there was a lot of tea in Julius and uh
oh yeah oh man too much I've got a lot
to say
I think you're gonna have to break it up
let's look let's start with like uh the
conquest of the Gauls okay okay so let's
start with uh because so we don't have
to go too far back but like we get the
preamble to the lead up of the uh right
overthrow of the Republic yeah right
because he was never an emperor right he
was assassinated before
Julie Caesar yeah
chat says Caesar and Brutus were the
original Frenemies so true
um Caesar made himself addictive of his
territories during his rule man my great
salad but he was just like the
generalist said I'm in charge now look
at me I'm the captain now I got um
distracted here by the Super Chat uh
Olivia thoughts on Sophie Turner and
Taylor Swift spotted together Queens
Queen of the North and Taylor Swift's
Queen of the South
[Applause]
all right that [__] of the West bad
[__] of the South Sam did you share
your opinion I did I did good she was
Pro uh I know yeah I intercepted her in
the back oh okay I said you got to go
tell the people right we love the Roman
Empire
we love the room we love love yeah we do
you know
um all right let's get started here
I got my ricolas sheesh I'm trying not
to smack into the mic is that that OG
again yeah OG kush yeah yeah let me hit
one of those [__] oh oh you got it no
almost sorry that was my bad I got it I
got it done
maybe he's got it Amy's got it okay just
go short today let's go get it slightly
sure it is I got it there it is I'm sick
that was a slick throw and catch and we
missed that one Ian just saying anyone
else Zach you want one in the back I'm
cool brother thank you
[Applause]
hold on Long bomb long bomb no way he's
got it he's got it
[Applause]
oh that's pretty close
round two round two ready it was it this
is it this is it this is it long bomb
[Applause]
thank you everybody I have a good arm
yeah we proved that one yeah with the
pizza one we proved it mathematically
you know with the baseball remember it
was he was throwing some heaters all
right you're right all right let's go to
whoop swoop there it is
so I'll say at the top this is all based
on
or I guess you you took a new angle to
this Olivia but uh so I want to stay at
the top yeah go to swoops Channel 100
watch her full interview with him a lot
of this is based off that interview
so if you if you're if you want to get
it all
her whole video is good so go support
swoop there it is there it is yes
um put it in the description yeah sure
yeah that'd be great okay so swoop had
Joshua Evans who is Colleen Ballinger's
ex-husband we've talked a little bit
about him she had him on uh her
documentary series and he told his story
about Colleen which he has not told so
far
in his life on YouTube and um he really
let a lot fly in terms especially he
filled in a lot of the blanks for like
me as a viewer at the time he answered
every question that I was like what the
[__] was going on at that time he gave
it to me so I obviously don't want to
sit here and regurgitate all of the work
that swoop did so if you want the extent
of everything I really encourage you to
go watch that I'm focusing mainly on
like the the questions that
freaked me like the answer is that
freaked me out because I've been I've
literally been wondering about it so
what is your thesis today this is I'm
taking you through the revelations that
are in swoop stock with Josh and I kind
of take you through the timeline of
their relationship so I'm gonna do
compare comparisons of like Josh's
recounting of a situation versus the
actual Vlog that like I remember with
Clips with Clips love that love that
beautiful yay beautiful
fantastic an explosive swoop exclusive
the Josh lean to Eric lean timeline
so let's ground ourselves let's go back
go back let's ground ourselves really
quick in this story let's make sure we
know who people are Colleen Ballinger
and Miranda Sings we remember her yes
Eric stocklin that is Colleen's new
husband Joshua Evans yes oh good uh Eric
stocklin we'll talk about it he was an
actor on her show Joshua Evans her
ex-husband Adam McIntyre YouTube fellow
YouTuber we have talked a lot about him
swoop fellow YouTuber incredible
documentarian Johnny we've talked about
him he uh alleged that Joshua was
grooming him and swoop
debunked that [__] she swooped in and
saved the day yeah so
Josh lean lasted from 2009 to 2016.
um people were UPS I was obsessed with
them if I'm being honest like they just
were the most wholesome I feel like I
think it was Jenna and Julian like
Colleen and Josh words it was their
on-camera Persona yeah just looked so
wholesome and like a nice relationship
like if you there I linked to their
wedding vid
um he literally like vlogged down the
eye
imagine your family sitting there like
the [__] is this bro
yeah if you Vlog your wedding it's not
going to work out Adam said it is that
um Colleen really didn't want him to but
he did it anyway oh that was his choice
Brave of Hope to admit that yes no no
Adam said that
oh Adam said that yes okay so then but
um if you're interested in watching it
you can we have a lot coming up though I
am of course
beautiful Facebook
yeah they deleted their original one
I love wedding videos they're so corny
so this is their proposal it started
with an edit this is 18 minutes well you
don't have to watch all of it you can
just click through it you can watch him
walking down the aisle is what I
expected so they're on stage well this
is when he proposed he was he took her
to a theater all of his like co-workers
were also there but she didn't know he
took her up onto the stage I can't
believe I remember this so well but um
yeah he took her up on the stage and
proposed apparently at the beginning of
that year she gave him an ultimatum and
was like if you don't propose I'm
leaving
[Music]
I thought was really interesting because
it doesn't seem like as soon as they got
married it seemed like she didn't want
anything to do with them right
and that she forced him to
yeah her career made a huge jump like
right after they got married so I wonder
I think that just like things were
changing for her and she was like oh
damn I like the way this life is going
[Music]
it was 18 minutes bro yeah just watch
him walk down there I'm gonna skip
around the grocery store is only I want
to see the Vlog down the aisle the video
of me crying was when I was watching
this
the way I go back when he comes all
right yeah oh brother brother put that
thing away man
that could not be less authentic you
can't do that that's crazy you know what
it's good that this didn't work out
because you don't want to have to show
your kids or people in the future your
wedding video and you're walking down
with a camera so that's that
music I don't want to play for too long
I forgot to check those kids are slaying
so hard love that oh
Jenna and Julian are sitting in the
audience
see there's Julian on the right oh sure
oh yeah you look so different he had his
ponytail he went so Alt
he's like an ALT boy
all right all right so I was just that's
Josh lean there's also Eric lean we
don't know really when they got together
it's very unclear we'll take you through
it however
they announced that they were dating
super close like weeks
before they announced that she was
pregnant and that they were engaged and
um if you want I I included their dating
announcement it was like embedded in
this weird video where she acted out
fanfic and it was not called with my
boyfriend first it was acting out fanfic
with Eric first and then in this video
they announced that they're dating when
like did anybody even know that she
broke up with Josh oh this is year this
is I'm just take we'll we'll go through
it yeah they've been divorced at this
time okay she announced that she was
um the next slide has the full timeline
written now if you want to pull that up
um
so they announced that they were getting
divorced September 2016 and they
announced that Colleen uh was pregnant
June 2018. so there's Gap in time and
I'm going to take you through all of the
times she was caught
next slide I'm gonna take you down yeah
yeah so
something that Josh talked about that I
thought was
really interesting was we even had a
conversation about the eyes
um
and he says that he knew those eyes and
the world had never seen it but this is
the most like authentic version he
thinks the world has seen of her which
is crazy
in that moment he's like I don't say
anything bad about her
but her eyes she's a demon from Hell bro
they look scary as [__] I thought that
was busted as [__]
he's like I don't want to say anything
bad about her but she is a demon from
Hell the way she is being characterized
now do you think that that's accurate
I feel bad answering these questions
yeah
because I don't want it to come off like
I'm on here to like bash her and drag
her
she's got enough of that happening
without being needed that being said
she's about myself
and honest with you and anyone watching
this it I think this is the truest
depiction of her that has ever been seen
publicly this is the most authentic
version of her that is
ever been publicized because when I
heard him say that I was like oh he's
out for blood well it's just you can see
it's so obvious like how hurt he still
is from the whole experience not taken
away from his pain she she's it oh she
what she did is just file but he's
really I was like oh damn brother he did
he kept saying he would hesitate
especially toward the beginning and he
was just like I don't want and swoop had
to say to him this is your story what
I'm saying tell your story
like especially in that but yeah the
ukulele video that's a version of her
that I know I know that person I lived
with that person is that her music or
art I saw those eyes she's saying to me
did she pipe in the creepy music she did
oh [__] it's wonderful everyone has the
ability serious change look inward do
the hard work I just don't think she is
yeah so that's that yeah so that's that
on that
um I'm hitting
specific key moments before we get to
the timeline just because I want to make
sure that I include all the stuff he uh
took accountability for the [__] Vlog
that one was pretty wild asked him about
that so did he say that it was happening
the two of you are very much insinuating
that she has her hand down your pants
while you're vlogging and that is
something that you filmed
and then edited and shows uploaded chose
the thumbnail did all of that absolutely
there's also the Miranda Sings kissing
tutorial what were you thinking in that
moment when you're filming this and
laughing about it and then editing it
and then uploading it and then leaving
it up there and then enjoying the
comments and the the ad revenue and all
those types of things I remember that
moment that it that she started to do
that and I was vlogging I could have
stopped
and I could have been like all right I'm
not filming this
but in my mind I thought this is just
our Dynamic we're being silly I really
thought to myself what I'm trying to get
I'm I want an audience that are not kids
okay so they did it they did that [__]
I don't know if y'all remember but it
was pretty weird there's a video of him
vlogging and then she just starts like
jerking him off yeah he
he oh my God you're
hit pants and she's like
and then they just giggle giggle and
then the Vlog is over here for you
[__] weird very inappropriate right
okay okay
um he also talks about I
noticed this when he started talking
about it
um she did used to like rough house with
him a bunch and I'm very it it's
definitely interesting she included a
clip she closed off I don't trust people
I never used to be that guy I was always
the almost like the golden retriever in
the room it's always like so
everything's good cool I know that you
beat me yesterday but I'm gonna come
love on me today not saying that she
beat on me I mean there were times that
she definitely smacked me around but not
not like we were fighting and she
smacked me I'm not saying that well I'm
gonna shift it I mean you know I'm gonna
ask was she physically we would never
get into an altercation where she would
smack me or anything like that but
playfully she would roughhouse with me
it was more consistent than I wanted to
believe so you think there was some it
was a lot of like
and I did it just like sparked something
for me where I was like damn they did
used to like play fight a bunch like she
they used to like smack and stuff do you
think she was taking out her aggression
on him no I just think it's it's really
it was a very immature way to
okay to act
yeah just super like juvenile he talks
about living with Corey
this guy's [__] weird brother
what was life like with Corey De Soto it
was hard because her best friend lives
in the house with them
with her and her kids and her husband
and he still lives with them now with
her dude what the [__] is wrong with him
yeah he moved out for a second and then
he came back yeah
yeah second's not good enough right dude
what
damn
you never felt like
I had a marriage or a relationship I
felt like I was a part of something plus
him and and I was there too everywhere I
look there he is I wake up in the
morning there he is I go to bed at night
he's going into today's room she made a
post on Instagram and she said that you
know this is my soul mate and I remember
looking at that
and being like well I would never say
that about anybody other than my person
do you think that was directed at you in
any way or I think she I don't think you
can you you know what you're saying if
you say that
okay interesting so Corey is like I went
to bed Corey was there I woke up Corey
was there you know what that means to me
Corey's her soulmate it means that we
can talk about like the sadist [__] that
we like to do well
uh Colleen's bathroom cleaner
our bathroom cleaner that's that's uh
that's life partnership right soulmate
[__]
okay
okay before we get to the timeline which
is next
this is also another moment where he
takes accountability for speaking in
those group chats and I'm curious
because you know we're talking kind of
there's these parallels right you know
you're participating in the content but
you were also participating just
on a No cameras around life happening
and you were in these tiny chats and uh
the group chats you know running around
town
um I'm not sure if you saw but Adam just
did a live stream today uh of a video
that uh was sent to him and it's on a
Fan's Channel they had done a vlog video
with you and Colleen and London and it
looks to be in Europe and they you and
Colleen are hanging out with these two
in a hotel room
for quite a period of time and you're at
a restaurant together but you were alone
in a hotel room with them and then they
looked like they were maybe backstage or
they were attending a show that happened
in that same trip and you know in
certain degrees I hear what you're
saying when you're talking about okay
things kind of spiraled they escalated
with the content and but the content has
a stop and a start you know start and a
stop button when you're recording and
you go through the edit process you put
it out there so that's one area that's
problematic you know at best but then
when we look at
you're actually physically
living life taking the photos and the
video that we saw you know you're
sitting on the couch kind of squeezed up
next
who quite literally says this is
uncomfortable or this is awkward you can
hopefully understand why there's so much
confusion and hurt and anger and
question about not just how is it or
sorry so he's is he gonna take yeah once
he once he speaks then we can
oh let's just say he takes
accountability he does yeah he does he
does and we love that right yes we do
and I really encourage you to watch
the full video
oh look at this hunky [__] all
right left
she he was so interesting things because
I I listen to most of it but he's like I
knew something was up when she casted
this guy to play yeah like a dorky loser
character I have that so um yeah this is
Eric stocklin before haters back off he
had little roles on TV shows not really
like major parts
um after he cast it after Colleen casted
Eric
um Josh said that he was confused
because
Eric's character Patrick was supposed to
be the male version of Miranda Sings so
like they were bringing in people who
were not conventionally attractive
people who were
like supposed to be gross and she was
just pushing and pushing for this actor
Eric who like doesn't have a like Angela
Kinsey from the office was in the show
so like there were people with credits
on this production but she really liked
this guy
yeah and he said it didn't make much
sense to him why I cast him right
um I have the link to that if you want
to watch that yeah I'll watch it real
fast uh I saw Eric
which is her husband now those eyes uh
right after I got off that phone call
with you and I I told him oh well I just
got yelled at by my husband for 15
minutes it was that something that you
you felt was happening often that she
would go to him and share details of
your
relationship I don't know if she thought
I was
blind but I saw it from the beginning
when she cast him I remember all the
other people that went through the cycle
of that audition circuit that character
was supposed to be not conventionally
like a good looking guy and when she
started you know wanting him I thought
he's kind of kind of a good looking dude
you want him to play this character
that's supposed to be like the the male
Miranda and I thought I can't say I
can't say anything she's going to think
I'm jealous she's gonna think I'm
nothing worse in relationship when
they're like you don't worry about this
person and then they end up cheating on
on you with them
those are the best parts
yeah
in the first few weeks of their
relationship first few months he
actually said that there was a tiff of
possible cheating that happened where he
found messages
so this is
2009. I was always interesting
is uncomfortable with Eric and her
relationship anytime I had an inkling do
you have a thing for that person it only
happened like three or four times
but every single time I had an inkling
it had start when you say it happened
are you are you saying that she had
cheated multiple times like with
different people or in the first three
months of us dating
I had this weird feeling in my gut and
that we were exclusive we were saying I
love you it was this Whirlwind romance I
had this feeling in my gut that
something wasn't right I didn't know
what it was and I did a foul thing she
walked out she was doing something she
left the apartment and I pulled up the
laptop that she was on and I read some
Facebook private messages that she had
been sending and I saw this part
she I mean ultimately
you shouldn't do that you shouldn't do
that you shouldn't go through your
partners agree stuff
um however it did happen with this same
guy again a few weeks later yeah
so that sucks though I mean I've never
suspected I was being cheated on like
that I guess if I really was paranoid I
might do that I've never done that
you've done that no that's a crazy thing
oh but if you suspect that like your
partner's cheating on you I guess maybe
I don't know
it's never a good idea I've never had
the the urge to check a phone just
because I I don't think I can get away
with it also not cool but also I don't
think I can get away with it it's not a
good idea for anybody ever okay
should I keep playing or you had
something to say
what's happening me oh I'm good
I'm talking to you oh no should I keep
should I play or should I
go to the next slide Nick you can go to
the next slide I told the story okay so
that summer before
she went for Eric Adam told this story
she went for this guy who was the
director of haters back off and
apparently she wanted him and she was
posting Snapchat stories and Instagram
stories that Josh references in the
swoop video that he was obviously very
uncomfortable with and she was like she
was trying to hook up with the director
first yeah
hmm
and there was Snapchat there she would
post I remember watching the snapchats
of her like running
down a hallway chasing him and like
giggling and I was like who the who is
this guy and I remember being confused
about it and it's just so interesting
that Josh is bringing it up
um things knowing that I had verbally
said that makes me uncomfortable hey I
saw on your insta story like you're
really flirting really heavy with your
director for your next book show like
it's there for everyone to see it's yeah
and if your partner
has the courage to
confide that in you then you definitely
need to take that seriously too if it
makes sense you know
because if it's unreasonable that's one
thing but
seems like there was some cause for yeah
this uh
where is it Leighton flirtation
the video of the director
um that was reposted cross-posted on the
haters back off which is the actual like
Instagram for their TV show so like a
video of her like giggling and like
going up close at her director I don't
know
me being controlling when I'm just
sitting here going your floor you're not
just like having fun you were flirting
and chasing this man down it's like like
me the comments are saying that you're
flirting she knew the things that didn't
make me feel great and she would do them
anyway she's flirting with the director
should I watch this one
let me hear it following him around like
flirting with him and stuff this is what
he tells the story he wanted that
I mean he was you know he was hot so I
mean
credit where credit is G oh wait someone
sent me something
I see this yeah
oh I'm excited I just tell stories and
the proof Finds Me
she wanted that before she wanted Eric
she wanted this do it again okay let me
try and get into the character okay
he's pretending to do Miranda
she wanted that do it again she wanted
that okay oh my God Bree remembers that
free was in the weenies
she wanted Andrea and then that night
the Snapchats I mean Snapchat goes away
after 24 hours and I couldn't find a
re-up but she was chasing him down a
hall and then like going at least at the
end like she catches up to him and
they're like giggling and it was like
just what the what are you doing and the
fact that her husband did show like
discomfort in it beforehand like it's
just why why are why do it okay why
participate in something that clearly
makes your husband uncomfortable she
seems to hate him based on what I like
but she seems to just not like him yeah
and there are there are clearly like
times where people are just paranoid and
it's like you're being you're not
trusting your partner right now this was
like she was clearly on the prowl to
find someone it seems like that's I
don't get it
just break up with your I don't know
let's keep going because it gets worse
VidCon story Josh is recounting yeah and
then we'll watch Colleen's yes
there was a there was a time right
before the divorce happened and it was
um VidCon
and she didn't stay at VidCon very long
she
at that point kind of thought I'm I'm
bigger and better than this
well I loved it
but she left and went back to our our
house that we had someone communicate
and relayed to me hey while you're out
at VidCon
she's having a few people over to the
house and I was like who
and they said Eric
Corey and a romantic interest and Rachel
and her boyfriend at the time and I just
thought it was weird and so I was
supposed to spend the night that night
near VidCon because it was a long drive
something in my gut said no go back home
so I finished the show I didn't tell her
and I got in the car and I drove back
she kept messaging me like are you in
your hotel room where are you where are
you and within the like last probably 15
minutes or so of the drive
I came clean and I said I'm actually
almost home this was so disappointing
why did he do that
I know I I wanted to ask him because
like I'm curious too if this story is
true the way he told it
sounds like he was going to catch her in
the act
but he right he blew it 15 minutes
imagine I mean
I'm sure he was anticipating how painful
that would be but I would want to know I
mean he's been driving that whole time
yeah I don't know and also it's so easy
to be like hey surprise sweetheart like
it doesn't even look bad sweetheart
you're like hey I just want to come home
and be with you it's like yeah but he
knew it was weird for him it feels like
and when I walked through those doors
it wreaked of alcohol and cigarettes
and no one was there nobody was there
and then I went upstairs
and she was sitting on our bed
playing her ukulele
I could tell she was she had some drinks
in her no big deal
she smelled of smoke
and
I was like what's going on where is
everybody oh they had to go they had to
leave and I just thought
just the red flags were popping off in
my head like why why did you tell her
why
okay so that's that right
now let me see what Colleen says about
that day interesting oh yeah I found a
Christopher I'm here
[Music]
I'm here Eric stocklin Eric stop wow
it's out to Eric for having an affair
with the married woman too right he
apparently at this time had a girlfriend
oh so double she tell she told Josh uh
after he said have fun [__] Eric and
ER I hope you think about me when you're
[__] Eric in our bed apparently she
was like it's not like that he has a
girlfriend is what her response was to
that Eric is playing Miranda's best
friend
um and he is one of the coolest dudes in
the world
Just In Those Eyes I'm sorry one of the
coolest dudes in the world I don't want
my girl talking about energies like that
yeah maybe I'm secure I don't know
I'm the coolest he's like a hot dude
that she's spending all this stuff he's
the coolest dude in the world [__] that
and at this point dude in the world yeah
[__] that
um at this point he's literally voiced
that he feels uncomfortable with her
flirting with people
[Music]
well it's just the day goes by and she
spends it with Eric and Josh is nowhere
to be found that was the content yeah
and it's just she she left it all out
that is pretty I agree I mean that's
pretty sussy if you want to see they're
like in a car to go about that and find
to each his own however he [__] in
Chris
follow me
I don't like that it's just yeah
not very nice if I saw my significant
other doing all this no it would make me
feel very bad especially after a
conversation right
okay yeah
so can we guess who else in the story is
involved why don't we look at this and
let's guess I know who's involved you
know who it is I don't what about you
who do you think you want to play
who's the best person to be involved the
funniest idea
uh PewDiePie famous YouTubers give me
someone else better funnier PewDiePie I
think is the only one right better
funnier I can't believe that they have a
leg in the story who am I missing oh
GloZell no but that would be funny that
would be funny I don't see Shane up here
oh oh that's Shane oh the answer is
Shane isn't it he's in the Middle top
middle oh this is oh I didn't even
recognize it's a demon photo you know
what okay yeah that is a shame at the
center of this right right she's at the
heart it all comes back to Shane doesn't
it girl Shane Dawson girl there he is
you did not you did not
so Josh reveals in his swoop video that
Shane Dawson in a sense crashed their
honeymoon
wait I didn't you see that part the hell
I was shown some things when I was at
playlist he was shown texts from that
took place during their honeymoon
receipts proof of things that she was
doing can you tell me their honeymoon he
was she was just texting him right Shane
Dawson I said in a sense he crashed
their honeymoon
hypothetically beautifully poetically
yeah part of me
still wants to protect her
because
what she was doing was awful at the very
least can you tell me what it has to do
with this specific one was
what she was saying about me behind the
scenes on our honeymoon
to another massive YouTuber she
basically said I told Josh some things
and he wrecked our hotel room she told
this to another large very large
YouTuber yes okay are you can I ask who
that was
why not Shane Dawson okay we went on our
honeymoon and we decided while we were
in Hawaii
let's go to the beach but I played
Devil's Advocate a little bit sure
I was watching this I was like well what
if maybe if she was telling the truth I
agree with you I think that swoop even
says like I would like to say Colleen
did not respond for comment like we
don't have her side of the story but it
is really in I mean compared to the data
that we have shows that she would do
something like that lie just blatantly
lie yeah I mean think about all the
other lies
well so this part in particular I struck
me as odd they're having their honeymoon
they just got married it's like the best
time ever and then supposedly she's
texting Shane Dawson during their
honeymoon which he says was perfect
right that he's yelling at her trashing
the room being a maniac and this was the
day that Colleen actually like would
talk about how special this day was
because they went to the beach without
any cameras and they reset their vows to
each other and so she would talk about
how beautiful this day was when they did
that and like
so who's to say however Josh is the only
voice we have right now and he says that
nothing happened and apparently she told
Shane Dawson that he was like abusive at
the time and then I also have the Vlog
the night in question I have her Vlog or
that happened a few times during this
interview where I was like what if yeah
what if what she said is what happened
yeah I would really
like to know
the truth
well if she were to talk about it she
probably would say that right I mean
what else is she gonna say
it's just like all of the blatant line
that exists in the story already makes
it just it just made my brain it made it
so easy to be like yep another horrible
thing she did
sometimes I got like a feeling though
yeah yeah about about Josh I just felt
some type of way sometimes was it worth
all the lie I didn't say that
remember the arrow where we used to burn
the witch
and let's say new vowels that are just
for us I mean the texts are certainly
confirmed like we've seen them we just
don't know if
why did you make that up you didn't like
lie about [__] like this point blank
live oh she she lied about a bunch of
stuff like she just made it up told
Trisha like nope they sent it to me they
were your fans they sent me your nudes
right that's her like covering up yeah
but here she's lying just making
something up that didn't happen
just out of the blue she's like hey
Shane I'm on my honeymoon and it's
perfect and my my now husband is a is a
monster
for no reason
it's just a little weird
I'm not saying listen no I know this is
it's it's important to uh to ask
questions but you know obviously uh
Colleen is the perfect villain and so
it's easy to just think of her as like
the worst in every situation
which she is you know right she is that
the next part is pretty if if you don't
want to watch the Vlog the next
slide is pretty crazy
the knight in question oh
yeah oh hell yeah dude
so it's our last night in Maui and clean
and I when we left to go on our
honeymoon
um we just had an idea if at some point
we wanted to stand in front of each
other without cameras and without a lot
of people and resay our vows our vowels
vowels I said vowels you said
our vowels
so we're gonna go and have some moments
and do that stuff
this is so Force I feel so like Ugh icky
watching this [__]
y'all don't have to be doing this man
what do we there's there was some
friction I saw a little bit of tension
that I didn't when I watched it for the
first time I watched their honeymoon
Vlogs when they were coming out as they
came out and I thought that they were so
so happy and now when I'm re-watching
I'm like they do seem a little bit tense
so I don't know I mean obviously we're
we're looking probably a little too
close here
but it is interesting I said valve
so to reset our vowels
so we're gonna go and have some moments
and do that stuff
there used to be a bunch of compilations
of her yawning when he's talking
he looks genuinely like damn like that
was because he he was doing the same
thing when she wrote him the song about
blue eye Joshua or whatever he had the
same kind of expression whenever she
would yawn because like she would do it
so much sometimes it was on purpose she
would like yawn while he was blogging
and at a certain point like after months
and months he would just like look so
sad when she would do it
what's this and what is this and what is
this so Josh explains in a swoop video
that Colleen was like I'm putting out my
divorce video now and you have to do it
now and he's like can we wait a second
and she's like no I'm doing it now oops
so uh if we want to pull up him telling
the story versus
the two videos
recounting okay
making that divorce video was
traumatizing she had just told me I'm
making a video to announce this and I'm
releasing it in a few days and I said
can we wait because you just threw this
big thing on me I didn't see it coming
I don't want to make a video about this
can we like just not say anything and
like work on how we're going to discuss
this and she said that would interfere
with her launch or her show and she did
not want anything to take momentum away
from her Netflix show and that she was
making a video whether I liked it or not
and
she started saying
I feel like that's counterintuitive she
definitely wanted
traffic
in terms of Gossip so that there was
more
eyes on her show no I feel like the
divorce yeah the divorce I don't think
she caused a lot of yeah nobody cares
people get divorced all the time
and people were talking about her more
so I feel like maybe she
was like I'm gonna get mine she wanted
to boost the ratings maybe it was two
weeks before
yeah you want to probably talk about
that a little bit beforehand that's
pretty wild certainly bad timing I don't
think that she planned it out but I
wonder if she thought about it
probably yeah I mean that's why what she
definitely did if she gave him a hard
day yeah
things that she wanted me to say so did
you feel that you felt then like your
your hand was kind of forced in that I
was backed into a corner
she knew that she had the power she knew
that she had the masks behind her and
she knew that she could say I just
watched his video about the the divorce
well okay so
something about their divorce videos is
clean in hers I remember she said like
Josh didn't cheat on me he didn't do
anything horrible to me please don't
send hate his like she said that flick
and Josh later talks about how he was
confused how the idea that he cheated on
her became a rumor and I I mean maybe
the weenies were like spreading that who
knows but I think it also definitely
came back to the fact that she planted
that in her video she was like he didn't
cheat on me he didn't do anything and
then like Josh also includes that in his
like he says like I didn't cheat on her
she did me like he kind of offhand does
that
but if you want to watch it yeah it's an
interesting watch let's so let's see him
do I need to watch this first part no no
I just explain it
so let's watch the two uh side by side
last thing I said to her that's like if
you have not said anything to her oh
hold up let me grab the let me watch his
first then
alone but I want it to be known that I
am not choosing this divorce
I don't want this divorce
I want her but I truly say something
that she
there was the whole thing about like she
sang the song to him about his blue eyes
but his blue eyes
right
he made a tweet I don't have blue eyes
yeah his eyes are blue
he was like they're kind of Green Oh you
said you could write a song about me at
least know what color my eyes are that's
what he said right and he posted a photo
of his driver's license where it says
that his eyes self-reported yeah my dude
you don't have green eyes you have blue
eyes you wish you know a fellow blue
yeah no but yeah because was he trying
to be dis deceptive about that right no
I think it was just a joke he was in the
comments and was like I know I'm just
kidding like it's just a joke he showed
the driver's license
I don't know it felt like a real thing
he was trying to do
I don't know dude he had Hazel's bro
like me
you have blue eyes Dan I have blue hazel
eyes
don't kill yourself they're blue Hazel
if you're gonna yell at Josh let Josh
yell at you all right let me see what
let me see what's going on here he
thinks that she's making the right
decision Joshua also made a point of the
touring band that I can't find them
sides led to the split the whole real
faithful the entire time is nothing like
that at all in in any way
I would never ever break that trust with
her so that's not this is not anything
like that and she didn't do it either at
the end
[Music]
video Joshua broke down while professing
his love for his wife and his wishes for
her he said he didn't take half and I
was like big mistake bro yeah he he did
uh they never pruned up and she decided
not to take any of her yeah I was like
bro I would have taken half of that [__]
if I got cheated on [__] up half down
pay up I think that's pretty cool thank
you
it is cool but then like
cool of him she sucks I think I would
have taken I want you should have taken
her money I'd be happy if you took her
money yeah I agree get paid dude if you
get cheated on man
take the money
right then
I missed what you're talking about
just take it if you get cheated on you
take that half if you get [__] like in a
divorce yeah that's what you're saying
yeah sure get get it get it thank you
brother yeah he also talked about in
this I didn't know he saved himself for
marriage
that's weird
I did not know that well that would make
the bond even more intense for him right
I think
he's no they had sex before they had
marriage she was grabbing his dick dude
he said no that was after their honey
that was after the monument that was
when they got back the day they got back
so was she but I don't know maybe they
did I mean I just know that he saved
himself in terms of sex I don't know the
the ins and outs of their relation but I
didn't know that I thought that was very
interesting
maybe that's what happened in the hotel
room
that's
just lost his mind he just comes he's
just [__] blowing ropes dude just
knocking [__] off the [__] wall
picture frames rocking World War Josh go
ahead FaZe Banks
that feed is all over this room yeah
yeah um I linked
that video oh thank you in Discord
dude he was a virgin [__] yeah
big mistake bro
he grew up really religious I
I do Wonder like
if you're really religious and you lose
your virginity when you get married
divorce has really looked
if you're religious yeah if you're
Mormon you get like removed from the
church well that sounds really traumatic
the Mormons are wild yeah I keep going
back to them man
you wanna is he Mormon no
too bad
he had that glaze huh yeah half glaze
all right here she is so it's gonna be
interesting she's gonna paint herself
she's going to try to paint herself as
the victim without saying it right
because she cheated on him and he knows
that
yeah
hmm
hey hey
um I am dreading making this video
the context was pretty funny when she's
like I'm putting this video out at this
day and time yeah I'm dreading
and I will not talk about it with you at
all
she's gonna see it
this video is courtesy of Team you suck
at the captions
thanks guys shout out to teamusuck.gov
or both ends of the magnet oh she is so
acting
okay so she's got a total this isn't
Broadway girl something that I noticed
in her Netflix show is that like many
actors she has a tell and I think that
her tell is that she like moves her
eyebrows a lot and like makes her eyes
go up an acting tell which like lets me
know if you keep watching the way that
she like manipulates her eyebrows are
very like
okay yeah I love that just pay attention
pay attention Ethan yeah I am I'm
watching her eyebrows
like when she looks up
like listen
you could have caught all this yeah
this screams fake to me this is fake
[__] dude it's completely fake there's
no reason to include you trying to catch
your breath and crying it's 50 seconds
of you just sitting there not saying
anything yeah Josh's video felt so much
more like he was filling the empty space
but it was so
empty can I say this is not do you think
it was intentional that Josh filmed his
in an empty house with boxes I think
that because I thought that was artistic
I think it added some Ambiance I think
it gave me what I what I needed
like that did you see that oh yeah
when she adjusts
there I have always shaped everything in
my life you guys and um remind me not to
play poker against Olivia
my relationship with Josh
so
to share with you obviously you guys
deserve to know what's going on
um
I don't want to get too deep into it
because it is very painful
she did it it's very hard for me to talk
about
it'd be easy to tell looking at this as
a fan to be like what did he do to her
that's what I mean in my brain I was
like
she's devastated something horrible
happened is what I assumed which is true
but she did it if you keep watching she
goes he didn't do horrible
oh [__] yeah he did it bad but not
horrible I want to start off by saying
um Joshua is a wonderful man
and I am so in love with him this is
nothing to do with
he's a bad person or he did something
horrible to me or anything like that
he's a good person and I love him um
it's like she's setting it up for a butt
right
slick that's the part I wanted you to
see she's a slick uh
slick operator
Smooth Operator so the divorce
announcements are out
the world knows damn and he says dating
yes man he shouldn't have said she
didn't cheat on me did you do that he
did it in a like very throwaway way I
think in the most like non-convincing
way he said it
so a few days later when she says that
she's taking a break from the internet
she posts a vlog and I remember being
very happy when this Vlog came out I was
like oh my God it's so great to see her
so this is a few days yeah which is like
her normal upload schedule her normal
episode schedule is every day so she
took two days off she took a few days
off like maybe a little less than a week
that's healing I'm Healed yeah I'm good
I love how she goes this is how demented
this [__] is you guys are entitled to
know what's going on in my most personal
life I found you guys are entitled to
know so I have to tell you crazy no
they're not
they're not entitled to know that
bro
I just want to tell you guys are
entitled
so I tried this new medicine to to to
treat my erectile dysfunction
and uh it didn't quite work so I'm going
to try this new thing
what's happening Dan
nothing's happening with me Zach is
still giggling at playing
Sam's crying
he kills me with that man
it's when he plays a family like really
quick that's what gets me I had to add
some spice to them I can't even look at
that
anytime we're past like I'd say like two
hours you could like faintly hear those
throughout the episode
yeah Zack starts to lose his mind yeah
I'm still reeling from Ethan just
randomly throwing in our group chat this
morning he just randomly threw out Z
money as a new name
and we were all just you didn't like it
no no we liked it but it just came out
of no we were talking about something we
weren't really like joking around we
were talking about something and then
you were just like just kind of casually
drop the Z money is that is that the
cold meds that were speaking for you or
was that just that was dead homie
speaking through Me Dead Homie
is telling stories I thought it was a
typo when you did it yeah I mean I was
that's the thing we weren't sure if it
was intentional or if you were trying to
say something yeah it was well there you
go thank you sometimes the world
Bob Dylan once said about songwriting he
didn't write the songs it was the
universe speaking through him right
right in his case which is why and he
goes I couldn't write those songs today
right well he sounds like a dying kazoo
now but you know
right yeah
well I love them though shout out to you
e so that's just the evil talking
through me
UE 40. that's the universe talking
through here the best one yeah I like it
the best line of slides is coming I'm
gonna play it because I want to get up
and get a drink but I'm gonna listen is
that okay
there is candy in my rug hey uh
I am on the internet
uh I look rough because I Am rough it
has been a rough
time in life recently everyone is
telling me to stay away from the
internet and
not post videos anymore for a while and
just completely stay offline
um
but it's making me really sad
so life is already really sad and really
hard and I'm going through just like the
hardest stuff I've ever been through in
my entire life and
um being online makes me really happy
and so to take that away from my life
and also to be going through really hard
things it's just not a good combination
so I really miss you guys and I want to
X back online I oh my God my job I like
making videos so I need to do what I
feel is right in my heart and I really
want to be on the line I want to make
videos
I'm not going to talk about it so let's
talk about it
right now what's going on what's she
talking about
stuff
videos because that makes me happy and
I'm gonna film that is the juice
here's the thing okay okay okay
I want to be happy
anyway let's start
but usually Lena's here to help me with
impatient stuff during the show but
she's not here today positive during a
time that's really so I the capitalist
Pig was forced to grab my own Saudi
banana
[Music]
all right Mr chair so this is when she
came back
there is candy in my rug hey uh what
there's candy in my rug what the [__] is
that she would start her Vlogs With like
one line of audio that was later in the
Vlog I hate this candy
why why you guys
what candy how do you know a candy was
in a rug she didn't even speak on that
[Laughter]
it's about to spit his drink out Ian
that's the one thing you want to say
today
that's your contribution
that's all you got to say
you won't you don't think about Rome he
won't switch to him
just keep it on Z money yeah Z money's
holding it down over there it's all good
can't beat get up another look at Z
money got the switching power come on
you let me have that one bro which candy
was in her carpet in
you watch this already you look look
ahead all right let's watch this watch I
am on the internet
uh I look rough because I Am rough it
has been a rough
you look like you always look like you
don't look rough you know you're fine
you look fine like let's be honest
recently yeah everyone is telling me to
stay away from the internet
[Applause]
more for a while and just completely
stay offline but we got bills girlies
she looks like a woman in love we got a
mortgage dude she's fine she probably
got
what's his name Eric Eric
is pipes uh derogatory she got piped by
Eric
dude she probably got pot she got piked
by Eric dude
probably just right before filming this
um
there were slides where she was caught
those are really going to come in handy
life is already really sad and really
hard and I'm going through just like the
office I've ever been through in my
entire life
[Music]
being online makes me really happy and
so to take that away and if only people
know that she cheated yeah well this
made me cry at the time I was like 14
13. if only imagine what the reaction
would have been if people knew the truth
of what happened
they're pissed at her dude not this pity
party [__] it's like she gets to
have her cake and eat it too it's not
fair
and Josh is off the internet moved home
good for him getting off the internet
the worst fate
right being off the internet that's not
true I think I think it's one of the few
times I've actually seen somebody go
through something and then they're like
I'm gonna step away from the internet
yeah I know that he that was the right
thing to do it's impressive that he did
that it really is
you know and I followed his I followed
him on Instagram like since back in the
day it's been it's been nice to see
where he's ended up for sure good for
you I agree
I see you girl I see you girl all right
we're done with this one yeah the pity
party
now then in the timeline that's when I
met her the next week
um we know that story though that was uh
when haters back off came out okay okay
the final text that Josh sent to Colleen
last thing I said to her that's like if
you have not so positive to her in
person the last thing he said to her was
when you're [__] Eric in our bed I
want you to think about me and then he
tells the last text
do you think that was the last things he
said to her I do because he he tells it
like I said that [__] I did you think
maybe he was like but can we said that
in his head when he was laying in bed
angry yeah the the idiot store called
and they're all out of you another
George Costanza reference dude that's
like my fourth one today well you did do
the Costanza pose the other day maybe
you're just like we're channeling the
character a little bit forget the Roman
Empire Seinfeld
how often do you think about Seinfeld
daily daily it has to be yeah for George
well I guess like that is like somewhat
more contemporary than the Roman Empire
I'll one up Ethan I think about it once
every three hours okay that's a lot
that's been that's that's a lot man you
beat me I'm Seinfeld brain dude because
every situation pertains back to
seinfelter curb four times this episode
yeah right no like it's just the truth
okay well maybe if you haven't watched
Seinfeld you're doing yourself a
disservice I'll just say that and I
really gotta watch it you haven't
watched it a b no I'd love to get I'd
love to know what you guys think about
it do you hate Jewish people
if you hate Jewish people you won't uh
only I think isn't Jerry the only one
who's Jewish in the show no George is
too no he's no he's not he's Italian
what yeah George Costanza Franken
Estelle are Jewish in real life they're
Jewish yeah I think they're all I don't
think it was ever explicitly stated if
he was Jewish they didn't they were they
did Festivus they didn't do doing right
no they're a talent George Costanza is
Italian
he's the most I mean obviously his
parents the Stillers are extremely
Jewish in real life Jew Italian Am I
Wrong George I don't think all I know is
that Zack's dog hates Arabs that's all
true no it's not true it is baby says
it's true dogs are can be racist as with
babies babies can also we were talking
about this earlier how has my dog been
racist
I love you I'm not gonna say
Frankenstein well hold on Amy you gotta
you made a bold claim are you talking
about Bambi oh you said I don't like
Jewish people that seemed a little bold
his dog
are you talking about bambia Priscilla
uh Bambi okay
and how you knew how
Brazil is a perfect little angel thank
you I appreciate that
and what did your dog do yeah what did
pampi do because He barked at you no I
just messed around because Bambi used to
come in here and only bark at me for
some reason that's funny I heard
Priscilla say she doesn't like gay
people so in the fatigues it's learned
that Frank's George's father is a member
of the Knights of Columbus in all
Catholic fraternal organization
there you go there you go but people in
the early polls I remember
uh they said of Seinfeld and focus
groups it's too Jewish
and it's funny because I mean obviously
yeah it's just just New York and Jerry
Seinfeld yeah and Elaine is like
ultimate goyum you know yeah he's a wasp
yeah
I guess they're all kind of like um
ambiguous like Kramer could be ambiguous
Kramer uh is oftentimes wearing a
wearing a crucifix in the show yeah
really
but they're ambiguous they're listen all
four of those characters are Jewish
Elena is like Jewish no but I'm saying
like not officially but like come on
come on but but in the Canon of the show
I think Jerry is the only one who's
Jewish I well yeah I dare I say who's
even more Jewish than Jerry they are
related Uncle Leo oh come on well it's
his uncle of course yeah yeah but he's
like everything that comes out of his
mouth is oh he's an anti-semite like
that's his response yeah I mean yeah
yeah no I think Jerry is is Jewish have
you seen every episode
yes I I have I think probably at one
point or another I mostly watch them in
syndication as reruns on TV and I watch
it all the time so I've probably seen
most of the episodes Brian Cranston
who's also Jewish in the show
anti-dentite thank you [__] that show's
crazy you guys you gotta watch cam is a
great uh Brian Cranston story that
pertains to Seinfeld wait what when you
went up to him oh yeah I saw him in a
play right after Breaking Bad ended and
everyone was wearing um Breaking Bad
shirts and everything to meet him after
the show and I went up to him and I said
Brian I loved her performance in
Seinfeld
what did he say and he giggled at it
he was great in Seinfeld yeah no I love
that character he plays a dentist too
uh converts to Judaism for the joke
so like the day after Jerry goes to get
his teeth fixed and he's popping off
with his Jew jokes
and Jerry's like is it really it's only
been a day it's been a day he's also a a
swinger and like gets really into uh
yeah
yeah what were you talking about
store called
okay should I keep playing this
um I don't know where we are yes because
we're I'm about he's about to talk about
the final text right final text here we
go
to me a few months later through text
that if I continue to talk about her in
any way shape or form is what she said
if you mention me in any way
I'm gonna get lawyers on you
and my response to that was
her branded
slogan all I said was spread happiness
but was that her was that her Brandon
slogan that's [__] awesome Yes her
slogan is spread happiness with a little
sunflower Thanksgiving Roman Atwood
smile more smile more smile more ant
would block dude spread happiness
hey I just thought of the Roman Empire
ninja Yolanda true
I'll tell you guys right now anybody
who's like spread happiness they're full
of [__] dude yeah anyone who's like
happy by choice spread happiness yeah uh
you know every single person saddest
[__] you'll ever meet it's all
[__] I promise welcome there's not
one serious person that does all that
all right this is my favorite part
play here or go back no no no next slide
next slide this is Aloha gate so aloha
gate took place November 15th through
the 22nd 2016.
um Colleen was caught
on her trip to Hawaii which she went to
like partially to promote Moana
um and partially for like a birthday
trip Moana what this is when Moana came
out Disney what was her involvement uh
the Ballinger Family were promoting it
they're just okay so um
Eric was not on this trip however the
day Colleen was leaving Hawaii a fan saw
them at the airport
with Eric in Hawaii
right so in that after that info came
out that a fan saw them at the airport
they went back to Rachel's blog and they
saw one camera frame right in the back
yes that's another Costanza bro on the
beach in the background of the photo and
he went he went there and tried to
remove it from the photo when uh it's
exactly it's the same hold on hold on
his boss right yeah
oh geez dude it's the same body language
[Laughter]
check this out
that's similar I guess
he gets a new job and then he realizes
that he had a huge [__] fight with
this dude's family on the beach
and he was praying he didn't remember
him and he saw this photo and he this is
before Photoshop so he went there and
tried to photoshop him out oh it's
fantastic you guys please and then they
like turn five times turn him into a
cartoon character or they they like
brush him out but the the boss gets
turned into it yeah
oh [__] dude
so good that's five times y'all and it's
all Costanza related
okay that's super that is super easy so
at the airport when the fan asked to
take a photo with Colleen and Eric Eric
said that he could not be in the photo
for contract reasons
that or oh maybe it's been a few weeks
since you announced your divorce well
divorce is technically a contract that's
true
but that didn't happen until October oh
wait but this is November so it did
happen that is that is red-handed man
right her family wasn't on all this [__]
bro that's cold man
because he was talking about how he
loved them he was super close with them
[Music]
cold cold
this is December 12 2016. dude there's a
Seinfeld where they go to the cabin and
burn it down the cheaper letters the
dawn the
um the cigars the cigars but they find
out that uh they're counterfeit well no
no no no no no when uh what what Susan's
dad was having an affair with that
writer
then they find the letters you know yeah
okay yeah
yo they burned the cabin down dude go
ahead sorry I'm not gonna stop doing
that that was another cassanza moment
though go ahead I'm not gonna stop got
it beautiful
um so Kevin Gates coolian goes to the
mountains with her sister Rachel her
sister Rachel's boyfriend at the time
and that's it we thought however
one shot from Rachel's Vlog go back I
love this go back so one shot in
Rachel's Vlog in the cabin shows Eric
this is it wait let me move this refresh
that page I just moved the cop thing
um oh it's a critical uh detail yeah it
is literally so important that was an
important detail
one pixel face but it's important
um after fans noticed that one shot
Rachel took it down and re-uploaded
without that shot
dead giveaway yes and Colleen even
hosted a live stream during this and I
remember watching it and she was like
I'm all alone in the woods everybody
left me and literally she's over
compensating yeah that's like Michael
Myers in the background
um wow that's pretty that's pretty good
one year later Aloha gate 2.0 a year
later can't they come out by now Aloha
2.0 Aloha gate 2.0 is one that I
actually caught in the moment like I
noticed it myself and by not reading
comments even I was like what is that
one was when the boyfriend or whatever
was in the background we didn't even
know he was in Hawaii Aloha too but
there was also the scandal in Maui
so is that like is that like the beta
the texting Scandal well their honeymoon
was in Maui that was before the full
version
Aloha three point oh yeah
don't ever call me a beta Bro [__] You
how dare you Aloha bro I I just cycled
that kind of language out of my
vocabulary yeah I don't say beta anymore
yeah
thank you so aloha gate 2.0 is the video
is called you caught me well that's the
day after so aloha gate 2.0 is when
Colleen got to Hawaii in 26 in 2017. so
this is a year later she is with for a
few days Angela Kinsey who is also in
haters back off but after like one or
two days Angela leaves and it's just
Colleen her family and Aaron and um on
this trip Adam says that Colleen was
texting in the weenies like Eric looks
so hot getting in and out of the hot tub
like [__] like that to kids and then on
the first you were saying that to the
kids yes she posted a vlog in her room
and she would just like was doing hula
dancing and there's men's trunks in the
shot that's disgusting bro and the the
telling the kids about the house what
the I'm getting so horned up right now
for real oh my I'm it's button me if
this is yo my [__]
to a bunch of kids
yo somebody marked me up
it's disgusting what's wrong with you
and I began to swear all right so
everyone was like oh my God are those
those are Aaron's Eric's trunks
literally like in your bathtub what's
going on did they pull up pictures of
him wearing those exact trunks yes okay
and um but the next day she posts a vlog
called you caught me where she says a
very elaborate story that explains why
his trunks were there but now we know
they were just together wow yeah okay
let's watch I'm not naked I'm wearing a
bathing suit um obviously I'm not naked
why would I be naked on the beach how
many fuses have I'm just curious oh
yesterday in my Vlog I was hula dancing
and there was something in the
background while I was hula dancing that
you guys all picked up on
ugh I can't do it doesn't disgusting
stop she gives me the evgb's upon
further
inspection a lot of you discussed it was
Eric's bathing suit dangling in the
background girl how were you going to
try to explain this you're in Hawaii
there's no way that man's swimsuit got
in your goddamn bathroom hula dancing
apparently to you guys the bathing suit
in the background proves that
um Eric and I showered together
this year we got to the hotel not all of
our rooms were ready yet so uh one at a
time our rooms became ready well hold on
now but we didn't even know he was there
right no we did oh we did yeah
oh at this point it's been a year so
Eric going on vacay with them he's been
in her Vlog so much recently as friends
that's like oh of course Eric will go
with them in Hawaii okay yeah yeah I
remember Eric's kind of a weirdo well I
think it's really interesting but like
his partner participates in all this
stuff you have to assume that he
co-signs it right a 100 of course
like he's just like in for the Colleen
right the toxic gossip train all the way
yeah he's does he have a career after
acting yeah I mean yeah he continued he
wasn't in like major major works but he
was in like Criminal Minds is he still a
working actor yeah I think let me pull
up his IMDb
I mean good for him I'm not trying to
like
just curious
came ready first Eric came up and took a
shower
I went in to take a shower and his suit
was dangling behind me but no Eric and I
did not shower together yesterday well
why even make the video just ignore it
well why even say like Josh didn't cheat
on me or anything it's like she's
planting seeds to be like just so you
know like I have stated I have stated
this isn't happening so like the people
on Twitter can be like no she said it's
not true I don't understand though she
trying to keep this a secret forever
well she they announced that they were
dating you'll see they announced that
they were dating uh getting married and
pregnant in like three weeks okay all
together wow yeah we made guys I have an
announcement we're starting a family for
real
um if you keep watching actually there
is a clip where like
weirdly it's like mocking the idea that
she likes him so she's filming and she's
like ooh so hot and it's like what the
hell there's a shadow walking behind me
in my room yeah or saying that I was a
liar is because of all the boys that I
was done through with were in my room
and so it's just funny to me that people
are so desperate to make me look like
this horrendous human girl why you're
doing you are but she's saying she
didn't have to do this she's like yeah
if I was having sex with him I would be
a horrendous person
and she is doing that yeah
you're single just get out there and
um he was in a TV show called good
trouble
when was that what year was it 2021 to
2022 good trouble I didn't um I only
actually I did hear about that because
she would talk about it in her videos
um yeah Costanza Luke he was uh he was
in two episodes of Lucifer
I hope this doesn't affect his career
negatively being with her because that I
mean I generally because that would suck
if he's got like a whole yeah thing
going
although yeah she gave him his big break
I think right
in the role of a lifetime in the role of
a lifetime Miranda Sings live you're
welcome
yo you're in trouble
okay whatever we love you Eric or I
guess I don't know so after Aloha games
yeah yeah I'm trying to find that and
see if he wants to stop and shower with
me Eric
I don't like her
[Laughter]
you suck I don't like her so and then in
summer 2019 this is after Colleen has
her first baby
um Josh was really not doing well and he
was an alcoholic at this point and he
posted a video where he was like I'm
gonna you guys don't know what Colleen
did to me but like I do and I'm gonna
tell everything oh and so this is that
video he didn't end up doing it
apparently Shane Dawson gave him a call
and talked him down
[Music]
you know
somebody close to you
his name is Shane Dawson what he says
goes in this town
are you sure you want to make that video
I don't think it's such a good idea
with all these texts you know flowing
around I was on a podcast saying you
beat her and all this you know
be a shame for that
get around I am the conspiracy guy you
know
I don't know that's crazy the Shane
called him
yeah held my tongue I'm actually glad
he's doing so much better this is really
sad
I was really scared I remember
he was in a really dark he looks really
bad here
it seemed like he was just like a
full-blown alcoholic he was he said that
there would be nights where he'd be like
I don't even care right yeah really sad
not like that James would take this
seriously
for years
two or three years I've held my tongue
more than you know
and it's killing me just say it bro tell
the truth do it now tell me about my
life and I want to tell you about what
really happened suck and it might
piss off a lot of people it might piss
off
the subscribers
and am I pissed off Colleen
it might piss off say it people in my
face
oh should I keep playing here no no no
you're good that was that video has been
taken down off the internet the fact it
was all that Preamble and then he didn't
say it yeah pretty funny it was like an
introduction video she's like I want to
tell you guys
yeah and he was like I'm planning on
telling you guys what's happening and
then I'm gonna get a call from Shane Don
yeah and then Shane really caught
blocked us with that oh yeah you're
gonna make a couple of statements on
YouTube we're in the home stretch by the
way we're almost done I feel you may
want to reconsider that option I know it
was you afraid
I'll put you in a conspiracy video what
College Square
otherwise
you might trip and fall
an alcoholic you never know what's gonna
happen
by the way
have you seen that Jada Smith
no good
no that's something Shane Dawson did I
know you're fired [__] that Jaden Smith
is something don't you think what
happened should have happened what
should have happened happened and well
said yeah nice dude by the way speaking
of Babylon reach they apparently put out
a new video today about
by you yeah about me and Hassan's epic
Karma confrontation
you're joining in on the farm ah you're
a [__] I saw one of the top comments
said what's happening to Ethan is the
opposite of what's happening to sneako
or the same thing but on the opposite
side of the political Spectrum where
you're seeing what your audience
actually is
stupid the opposite end of the political
spectrum of it's saying yeah he's saying
that like Ethan's realizing now that his
audience is is so [__] up they're all
Communists that's literally not what's
happening yeah I know she doesn't know
what's happening I I know people are so
desperate to make that parallel it's
like yeah look we have 56 000 people
watching live nobody gives a [__]
we're talking about swoop over here you
guys see swoops and chat I know we have
swoop she is she said hey just wanted to
say I appreciate you great PowerPoint
Olivia and Olivia and Ethan I hope you
feel better soon
love swoop good work literally
incredible work
everybody go watch that video definitely
definitely it's in the it's in the
biology give all the healing by the way
can we talk about how being a socialist
is not equal okay let's not talk about
that right now why are we in the middle
we need to say oh we're talking about if
you're a socialist is not the same as
someone saying let's kill all gay people
that's not the same that's not right
they're right let's not make that
parallel yeah okay that's what I'm
saying it's so insane that's what I
thought it was funny it's not the same
guys even if you think that like
whatever is happening with me that's not
the same thank you I agree beautiful I
rest my case amen not your fault well I
don't know um reach what do you think
about it's not your fault what did you
have to say about it something about an
omelette
hmm
put some wisdom from reach and in order
to comprehend you're gonna have to break
some
comprehend in order to comprehend to eat
the other the omelet of knowledge you're
gonna need to break
yeah he's a very analytical mind
all right and he was right about it
very good so this is something that went
under the radar for a while this is
Josh's old friend about a month and a
half ago on his podcast he used to be
friends with Colleen and Josh he's a
YouTuber named
his last name is green but he's Versace
now what's going on yes he's all swagged
I've seen him on JK news I think Swag
yeah so he basically gives his two cents
on like their Dynamic and what it was
like and he basically is just like
Colleen's a horrible person talks so
much [__] this is the one who showed
Josh the screenshots from Shane Dawson
at Playlist Live where he was like dude
did you see these texts that Shane is
passing around that looks like
yo brother that's fake Versace right
there there's no way speak on my man
like that there's no way that's real
look how much it looks so oh yeah it's a
goose yeah yeah
manipulation oh you do yeah so this is
from two months ago
yeah a little late yeah could have
spoken about it earlier
yep
yeah I agree I thought this was going to
be like from five years ago or something
oh no
you guys heard well okay we know that
where do you know that right but the way
he speak he's like damn he would leave
the room and she would just go hang out
on him about Miranda Sings AKA Colleen
Ballinger this is kind of a weird topic
for me because I know these people so
this is gonna be a little weird still
the [__] Bean Steve okay so uh this
is one of those crazy things right so
you when you know somebody you don't
necessarily know everything about them
obviously that's what everyone says
about serial killers and like everyone
who's a neighbor that was a funny now
dude these team's neighbors like Peter's
the nicest [__] yo that necklace looks
fake bro what is that woo necklace
who made that brother
I'm kidding
I'm loving the guys
[Music]
I mean like how would they know yeah
like this like three times and all of a
sudden they're the nicest guy in the
neighborhood you don't know anybody you
don't [__] know so when I knew
Colleen Ballinger she was doing the
Miranda Sings character and
um where did you meet her I'm like
there's so many people there dude it's
sick it's kind of fun Concepts they're
just sitting yeah it's like a round
table you think people don't say that
about this well this format is weird go
to go to five minutes that's when he
starts talking about like the mean stuff
oh go to five minutes ago yeah
you thought this format was a good idea
so there's a kid named Adam McIntyre
who's come out about this situation he
was in that weenies group that I'm
talking about and apparently like as she
like you know
she was with her husband and the big
thing about her and her husband was she
would talk [__] on her husband like
constantly to the kids to everybody well
was that a joke or was that real it was
real that's what I threw out all this it
just feels like she hated him the whole
time she just hated him it feels like
she just has a lot of hate for like she
can just talk [__] it sounds like I do
she likes to well I do wonder if she
treats Eric the same way I do wonder
that as well
it's possible it's more than possible I
hope not that she's just a toxic partner
yeah it was the real [__] I was just
venting about venting about her husband
like being embarrassing she's humiliated
by him at all times which again it's so
weird because she gave him an ultimatum
you must
propose to me yeah Josh says in his
interview that he felt like he was just
playing a part and that like he just
didn't fit the quota anymore like he was
just replaced right
like just talking the most [__] I've
ever heard of human being talk then why
is she with him dude it was weird all
right yeah he also says Corey de Soto's
the meanest [__] he's ever met
in his life oh I do that dude so weird
bro Corey's got bodies in the basement
he's got a group chat called Corey's
clits
um there's something off about that dude
who wants to live with Colleen's family
thank you Dad the next one is a clip of
Colleen after she announced that she was
with Eric and pregnant with her first
time she's making fun of Josh she's
making fun of Josh I don't know came out
with an EP and she's saying that he
stole the song from Jason Derulo so be
careful when you click because at one
point she plays the songs on top of each
other and one is a Jason Derulo song but
she's just saying that he like copied
wait this was a private video yeah she
sent this to Johnny is the one who put
this out before honey no puppets exposed
to him dude what is wrong with her why
is she friends with these kids at this
point John uh Johnny was of age but like
a fan he's like a he's like a a die-hard
fan
why do you need she's so like insecure I
think she truly must be a narcissist
because like she needs that worship she
needs the Adoration that's why she's
connecting with the fans she needs the
warship
people need to see her like the god the
Goddess that she is and they validate
like every move she makes and she needs
it and kids are like so impressionable
and they don't
they're not going to see through
anything and they're just gonna be all
worship we love that don't we call him
we do
so I met I made um but if she's just
talking to a friend about it I don't
really care I don't think it's that big
of a deal no it's a it's a fan that she
that now works for her who used to know
Josh I know but it's not a pup she's not
publicly but still weird though and we
know Johnny's Johnny's snake-ish yeah
well you know like he always talks [__]
about like other if you're with your
friend and you know your ex-husband you
you make a comment or ex-boyfriend I
mean you know there's a big difference
between talking and private and talking
in public I guess I just feel like I
hope one day when I'm pregnant and
engaged I'm not talking [__] about my ex
probably not a yes that would that would
indicate a healthy mind and spirit thank
you I will strive for it I'll watch it
though just because why not okay Jason
Derulo song a step higher to see if they
are the same and they are and I will
show you I mean they are kiss the
receipts girls
oh I hear it what the [__] was that
all right whatever she just she's being
a dick yeah so the next one this came
out on Twitter yesterday or the day
before and apparently she had an inside
joke with the weenies where they called
Josh Pinky and they would take photos
holding up pinkies
do we know that it's specifically
because of his genitals so the comments
guys we referred to Josh as pinky for a
very long time connect the dots and Adam
on stream it seemed like he was
insinuating that it is correct first of
all these are children you're talking
about
they're the ones putting out their
little pinkies they're these are kids
why are we talking about your
ex-husband's genitals and this also
wasn't the first time that I've heard
that she would talk about like Eric and
Josh's sizes with them like this isn't
the only she used to discuss their penis
size with the kids that's what this is
apparently too
I didn't know all that that's [__] up
bro she did freaky [__] Club she's so
crazy but yeah apparently that's what
also like you [__] up it's not cool
like to be making fun of his manhood
right like come on that's such a low
blow and for what reason you're the one
that
cheated on and he covered for you man
yeah this
he could have gone harder
yeah he said she didn't cheat on me no I
mean in the swoop interview too I think
he could have gone harder really I think
he could have he could have made it
really really messy and he did Lay the
truth out but I don't think he got as
messy as he could have
that's why I wanted him to call him
because I'll get a messy I would love
that
that's my specialty yeah
pinky dude that's so [__] up put that
thing away Colleen should be ashamed of
yourself the kids put the the kids in
the binky next one's got braces
what are you doing I hate that yeah
uh I'm having a moment here with this
pinky thing it's gross
and she would tell her weenies that her
new husband was better endowed
I I mean I don't know if that's exactly
right I can I can that's giving p word
maybe in my opinion talking with kids
about that that's exactly what it was
it's weird
um
for sure I don't know if she said Eric's
was bigger than Josh's I want to see she
said that I wanna I wanna clarify that's
so [__] up like come on
what's your argument
oh [__] my mug he's out sheesh
all right whatever let's keep it moving
you know what I mean let's keep it okay
thoughts oh that's it that is everything
oh there's nowhere to move thoughts is
that she's a b word and Josh is uh was
screwed over by her yeah I hope he's
healing
and I hope that Eric's not a hostage
yeah I hope that Colleen and Eric have a
healthier relationship for sure
for the sake of all of them and their
kids for sure I always felt bad though
she's going through all this stuff just
because she's got three kids and yeah
your kids know when you're not present
it's hard man when you're not present so
hard
okay hopefully that's the last time we
talk about
Colleen right Dan
probably cool
no more Colleen no more Josh unless he
agrees to call in right and spill all
kinds of teeth
unless he's unless he's gonna call in
and gush like Miranda's vagina when she
sees okay her new husband coming out of
the hospital that's what she said I mean
let's be honest Colleen Did use that
verbiage
she said that two young fans
oh did I miss that part she said that in
one of her next Corners remember that's
why I said she's like remember the
teenage girls and it was like why the
[__] at least I've seen what a vagina
looks like
good for you tip cheers my dude all
right
so let's see we have Russell Brand and
uh yeah so that's a big beefy story and
so is the other thing it is uh no I can
do a passenger not Smoky flavor okay I
can do a passenger fast and then we'll
do the Russell Brand thing on Friday I'm
super into this Russell Brand
um story there's so much ins and outs
and details it's fascinating it really
is and of course with all uh you know
it's with all respect to the victims and
stuff who I who are one thousand percent
telling the truth
um
but the way that he's he's
uh engineered his defense is so
transparent and it's it's really amazing
to see
just how the right wing
the Griff just will take anybody in man
it's awesome
let's talk about eight passengers so
what's up what's up Ruby Frank's two
sisters posted individual videos
addressing the situation okay
Bonnie one of her they're all family
vloggers by the way
so they're all like
feeling the
feeling the guacamole well try up
title I am not my sister I am not my
sisters I wish there was a guacamole
well
did you dip into that oh well
oh wow love some guac
so I'm it's nine minutes let's see
what video to make I know that
my words will be used against me I also
know that my words may help girl you're
perfect
what is happening find a [__] less
echoey room
I think you should retire if you haven't
figured out how to do audio by now
sounds like [__]
biggest emptiest roof you can find
she's sitting in the Mormon Church yeah
she's in the in the Tabernacle that
doesn't make sense with how bad the echo
is
for myself other than
um the judge has asked us not to speak
on
certain topics that I I'm bored I don't
care
oh my God
the thing is if like I you're not your
sister you're not your sister's cry
it's just that you're all family
vloggers it's just weird it's so weird
what's your argument you sound like
I don't know
these people they're like you put it you
put it well they're also glazed it just
lays up yeah
just a glaze to the eyes
let's fast forward and you see here's uh
most watched spot let's see what she has
to say what was I going to
[Music]
don't like my sister and I don't always
put some EQ or something on there you
know that is what we kept quiet about it
wasn't what the [__] she said yeah why
is there they kept quiet about them
cutting us off because we didn't
understand why they did it
that is what we kept quiet about it
wasn't until about a year ago when we
were able to connect with Sherry I don't
know there is no comment bro we're gonna
be hearing the echo when we cut the
stream
it's still resonating three years ago
Ruby and Kevin cut our family off and
eventually lady what the [__] that's
like a day one video
I can't deal with that I said no her
other videos can't be like this right
uh well there's in the dock there's like
a little summary and some time stamps if
you want to Wade through this upstairs
and the main floor all oh they just
bought a new house same color and the
same Sheen and it's echoey it's mood
okay whatever I know you don't your
sister you know your crimes it's just
weird those things weird update about
the pinky thing apparently Colleen would
call Josh Pinky and then she would
insinuate that she was much more
satisfied with Eric that's so freak yeah
that's not cool oh man what did he do to
deserve that that's like the meanest
thing you can say I agree it's a 12
incher but I give it a light six
[Laughter]
um
so in this video she says that they
didn't know the extent
and that she left the family three years
ago
they just moved into a new house with
with horrible acoustics
she says her anger sets in because this
casts a bad light on her of course she's
the victim
right let me open that let me open that
poor woman let me let me hear how she
delivers that line Papa's in the house
this is where my aunt
a horse light on me
bro what about this kid in a cage
and I have decided that I am no longer
allowing them to to have any control
over what I do I didn't post because
okay yeah the kids were probably the
biggest victim but yeah I guess she made
you look bad too ready to go buddy
I do I feel terrible about that
Bonnie will not let Ruby or Kevin be the
reason she stops posting yes girl don't
ever oh this is so empowering we need to
make never stop vlogging Vlog forever
smile more
smile more damn it just never ever do it
it is death Ruby will not keep me from
smiling more and connections and Jody
take one more thing away from me so you
better believe I will continue to post
because
if that is what tiny control I have left
I'm gonna take it I'm gonna take control
can you do what I feel
Ruby was probably the one that gave
these people careers right she was the
she was the Vanguard of the family
blogging that's a good question I I
don't know which I mean family members
started all this here's her other story
Julia's
Julia Madness yo I did the whole thing I
think the DayQuil actually helped
Frankie who was arrested a few weeks
that's just bust him
[Laughter]
it's that double shot that's just
busting it hit me with that double
can I get a double DayQuil on the rocks
yo give me that double double nothing
what's the most I can take of the [__]
in a day
well you should not take any more right
now why because if you're gonna be
driving home in a yeah don't operate
Machinery on this uh I think it probably
does the NyQuil does
the DayQuil does it as you could show me
where it says that I don't think it does
the NyQuil definitely does bro's gonna
be driving like Mario Andretti up in
there
oh this car
take uh only use do not exceed four
doses so that means I could take another
double oh there we go I think they got a
double bro on the Rocks straight
I could take it a little dirty straight
up
well that's never mind
uh you want to see the bottle I can
drive on this bro yeah it's uh I guess
it looks like it's fine I don't know I
can drive on this [__] you wanna drive
with me I'll prove it to you
I'll drive you home
like a seasonal
I swear I drive better on DayQuil please
take off
please hit I guess they'll drive
I've had so many alcoholics just tell me
I drive better when I'm drunk driving
okay cool dude that sounds good I'll get
in yeah
so here's her other sister uh Julie
you just go for child abuse by now you
probably know that you also probably
have seen my sister Bonnie's video I was
much better audio let's give it up
yesterday or today and she knows how to
record I couldn't bring myself to do it
I've been trying to gather my thoughts
for several weeks and I don't think I'm
ever going to have my thoughts
completely put together here because
it's it's involved so many people
there's so many little details I am not
going to be a news update I will not
update you on news I will not give all
of the little nitty-gritty details I
don't even
I know I don't need to sit here and
defend myself I know I don't need to go
into the history of what has happened
um so we'll see where this goes and how
much I get into but let's see how it
goes we have been extremely hard not
only did all that happen with Ruby but I
had just moved to a new state and Landon
had to go back to Utah to finish up his
dissertation for his degree and so I've
been settling into it that is hella
great I was about to say that bedroom
looks like the [__] place they
recorded The Exorcist why does it look
like that like two matching yeah the bed
is she's married right because that bed
is not big enough for two I feel like
nah well that's like a twin bed look how
small it is maybe they have another twin
bed matching on the other side like old
style they would do that husband and
wife shouldn't sleep in the same bed
they only sleep together when we're
trying to when we're fornicated right
all right go on tell me more
the kids without his help and all this
fell down so I've literally have not had
the physical or Google can I drive on
DayQuil
because it's fine right it said avoid
driving and hazardous activities until
you know how DayQuil cough will affect
you your reactions could be impaired oh
but then do it on NyQuil see what NyQuil
says they'll be like don't we're not on
NyQuil no but I'm just as compared just
curious yeah you know well we know the
answer is no drive on DayQuil they said
just see how be careful yes right which
I've done clearly I just did like three
hours blasted on this [__]
uh yeah you can uh what a surprise you
can't you shouldn't drive all night
don't drive a nightclub DayQuil thoughts
nailed NyQuil uh
[Music]
that's what the [__] is up
now hit me with that double
a double
um extra dirty
emotional capacity to address anyone
three years ago Ruby everything was
great it seemed to be fine anyway we
were typical family she was getting some
therapy counseling because their family
needed it which I think is great however
I think you need to get it from a great
source read the reviews Jody Hildebrand
and her website or therapy style I don't
know what you want to call it
connections was not a great resource and
we all thought we all felt weird about
this Jody lady we didn't we weren't
comfortable with it we didn't like it we
didn't like the teachings
functions and we were this close to
telling her if you could do my family
doing something you guys did you hear
what you were learning I swear to God we
were this close to doing something
really oh I was just I was so close I
don't understand man it was like no I
was like I was like something but then
right there right there just about it's
almost like we did something I'm so
curious what the teachings were that
they didn't like that they just stood by
I know I never got a chance to watch
that [__] because I got nuked right I'm
so curious
but I think it had something to do with
torturing your kids it was like the love
is not unconditional for children
so Vibes so Vibes unconditional love is
a conspiracy created by the globalists
yeah yeah be a good child
learning through connections because we
don't like it we never did say that to
her but we thought it
um anyway so three years ago Ruby and I
hung out doing bottling tomatoes and
then a few weeks later
crap hit the fan and she left the family
and she didn't even call me to say Hey
you know Julie you're doing this and
this I don't like it you're living your
life in Distortion so I'm gonna have to
take some time away from you no
literally nothing she did call my mom
and yelled at my mom on the phone for 45
minutes and accused her of things that
were not true
it was almost as if Ruby had been making
up memories from her childhood what are
you doing dude
stop you're boring
she's making up memories
what are you talking about make a good
video
you just said Ruby's inventing memories
it was almost as if Ruby had been making
up memories from her childhood she was
trying to grab it anything she could and
she would exaggerate on everything so
she started all of her lies back then
lying to everyone in her life
getting rid of all of her friends and
family and whatever they were this close
that's the important part yeah
yeah you guys you don't under even
understand like when two lines intersect
like and they just keep going closer but
never touch it it was like that it's so
close it was like infinitely close
frustrating
am
you know
okay fantastic Julia mentions that she
is also moving into a new house Vibes
good for you girl both of them she
doesn't feel do what a beautiful timing
for them yeah they're both they're both
moving they're going through they're
doing wonderful they're busy she doesn't
owe anyone the explanation she
reiterates everything her sister Bonnie
States her video about disagreeing with
Jody and Ruby's teaching
she was finally able to form a
relationship with Sherry Ruby's eldest
daughter when she turned 18.
Julie says that they had no idea what
was happening
that they will not let rupees evil take
more happiness for them okay I mean they
say they said they disagree with their
teachings
she says she re-enter here let me pull
it up
I feel like it and it goes beyond that
it's not really it's just something it's
not like cup of tea listen you raise
your kids that way you you tie them up
with rope and and uh and torture them I
I'll do something else over here it's
all you know it's just
Live and Let Me
Live and Let Die
um
foreign
you know that song was the um
theme song to a Bond film really that
died yeah sick and um that's a good
soundtrack and James Bond was an MI6
agent from the United Kingdom
the United Kingdom the British Isles was
part of the Roman Empire at one point
yeah it was it was you forced that
that doesn't count
when I was
all right go
we all thought we all felt weird about
this Jody yeah we didn't we weren't
comfortable with it we didn't like it we
didn't like the teachings Ruby was
bringing to the family functions and we
were this close to telling her I didn't
like this
oh shoot they were this close to telling
her off
that's crazy
function but look how close her fingers
are
they were so close to doing something
doors read the reviews Jody Hildebrandt
and her website or a great resource and
we all saw it we all felt weird about
this Jody lady we didn't we weren't
comfortable with it we didn't like it we
didn't like the teachings Ruby was
bringing to the family functions and the
family functions where they do like
parenting workshops together
dude look how closely we're to doing
something though that's so close she
practically did do something would you
say that's like an inch that's like half
an inch bro you think it's under an inch
definitely that's pretty close those
fingers are closed that's pretty close
and I'll zoom in version I'll zoom in
it's very it's like minutes right you
see how close she was to doing something
well you can see it's like um
it's kind of going about half the
distance of that of knuckle to knuckle
what would you say that is I mean half
knuckle knuckle yeah I think you're
right maybe maybe even a quarter in
that's really close
super close she looks like she has
rather small hands so yeah it'd be a
quarter inch to telling her
connections because I love that so so
what she's saying is we never complain
and she continued to come to our family
conventions and tell us to uh lock our
kids up with in basement with duct tape
and starve them
thank you
congrats on the new houses I'm I'm happy
for them it's good keep up the good work
Julie and Bonnie you guys you guys did
good
all right I did it y'all [__]
y'all said I couldn't do it and I did do
it
wow you look good no I'm not glazed up
good like that my beard is too patchy my
teeth aren't perfect yeah your eyes
aren't Hazel enough to write them up
exactly well hold on yeah that's way too
Brown that's way too Brown I may be
Hazel
it's just the light dude you know how
Josh his eyes didn't look blue on his
his eyes always look blue and that was
complete cap
your cat
got him okay all right what do you guys
think about all that we did it we did
most of it we did most of it here's the
thing
tomorrow's leftovers at 10 A.M come
because it's gonna be fireworks dude
it's gonna be explosion why are you
setting up 1776 dude okay it's the Red
Scare all over it's the Roman Empire bro
socialist you're gonna start rounding us
up yep socialists be gone you're
bringing in the pinkertons
how about you're gonna scab I'll give
you a scab wait that's it
we love Scott I love scabs
I pay them I'm paying you know why Bill
Marsh city is going back to a show
because I offered to pay him
I said bill you have to go back for the
people scab
it is it's actually awesome the two
people who said they were gonna scab
Bill Maher
and [__] Drew Barrymore they both
already they back down rebelled yeah
which is so funny because basically they
got the worst of it and didn't even get
to go back they just got humiliated very
stupid and then sent back on both counts
I think I saw Sam Cedar say it and it
was very good point he goes what are you
gonna do on the talk show nobody's gonna
show up to your show
guess what you're not gonna get any
guess right yeah yeah or crew or crew
who's gonna work your [__]
I mean that's the thing you know what
you're gonna work you know what's gonna
happen if Bill Marsh decides to shoot
his show it's gonna look like this watch
this is this is Bill Marshall with not a
crew
[Music]
[Laughter]
against me
oh thanks Zach
well cheers to you guys cheers needs my
help with lots of stuff at home so I'm
gonna need this um hold on
I mean
I hate to uh
[__] your [__] up with uh
with Ela here but this seems important
go ahead I don't know if it's a troll
don't know if it's a troll
but theoretically Aiden Ross is about to
speak to Kim Jong-un no [__] way oh
oh pull it up is that him
oh you don't see my screen hold on this
is not really happening hold on that's
fake that's not Kim Jong-un that's just
like yeah it's a troll it's a troll look
we just we this is live so we we just
saw it that's really good so it's enough
I think to potentially start a war it's
really quite custom it doesn't look
anything like him he's a much better
looking kind of weird oh yeah oh yeah
much better oh yeah and that's why he
should come on the H3 pod yo Kim come
bro
maybe that's why he's so bulked up
because he doesn't poop he just he just
holds it all
and gotta ask him Kim
all right well we had a good old [__]
show here
and just bring your um Kevlar for
tomorrow
because them bullets gonna be flying
you know bring your stab proof
shirts which I know you all have yeah of
course because stabs and bullets will be
flying
order your Domino's might be the last
episode
if we get Dominoes it will be
um
it's all happening tomorrow
and I'm ready I am ready
to defend daddy capitalism
I say that facetiously I'm not defending
capitalism I'm defending social
democracy
hell yeah baby this is Who We Are
dance position more like
um
hold on
foreign
[Music]
oh Dan yours is more like the National
Association
shut the [__] up
I'm just Social Democrat
you know
I should have never given you that word
uh-huh you got the music playing this
song
you have a lot in common actually with
Kim jong-un's politics he's also a
glorious socialist leader that's right
[Music]
shout outs Joseph Stalin right shut up
he was a powerful communist leader sure
sure was we're gonna have fun tomorrow
there is no uh there's no murder as
capitalist leaders that's for sure
it's I'm not kill well as long as you
don't kill your own people it's kind of
you know what if you do both
then then I guess you get a better
higher score no that's like zero KD
that's not like yeah I mean
KDA was crazy yeah like who has a KDA
like Stalin bro
you know what I mean
Kim Jong-un might be topping our list
Kim jong-un's got a good kid here not as
good as Tom though bro no shot a lot of
people died dude Stalin killed like tens
of millions okay yeah bro he's a [__]
king of that [__] Kim Jong-un can't the
people just die because they don't have
food I don't know if that counts I think
that counts you've got a couple of M's
maybe that counts yeah I think so how
many people live in North Korea
it's a lot
let's see
Bobby North Korea 25 million oh my God
that's horrible
that's a big country yeah
Joseph liked out that whole country
though
and that's why we call him sloppy joe
sleepy Joe he wasn't the Sleepy Joe that
we know
he was woke Joe he was awake and he knew
how to take action
cheers he was a man of action cheers
it's just the DayQuil speaking through
me
cheers
[Music]
oh [__] is that the police
hi uh
yeah uh what tell me Ryan Cavanaugh
wants to got into this what do I just
tell me what do I do
oh that'd be a big donation to the
Sheriff's Office
I can do that
it's not it's Oak it's Coast dad
cheers
coach my dad cheers
[Music]
all right
Genghis Khan good KDA yeah but he
spawned a lot of people too he wasn't
really a socialist he's won a lot of
people too yeah he's part of pun I don't
know that's true he which right he take
he gives any take yeah I mean he was
more fair it's so funny he wasn't a
socialist though closer he just said
yeah he's probably he's the Lord yeah
closer to a Lord and not like in the
nice English sense more like in the like
yeah like those nice English words
tyranny says shout out
there it is
oh my God kitten
is this a recent one dude he looks good
I love weight loss stories
[Music]
he's glazed bro what you oh [__] you're
right these places
and ointments are you on brother he
needs better teeth though food warming
those teeth are a lot well that's a
that's a coffee that's a dupe oh it's a
look-alike dude his aids always looks so
[__] miserable
and scared they look scared
look at this guy he's seen [__] man
oh glorious leader you look so good he
really lost a lot of weight he looks
good doesn't he we're happy for him
all right
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
foreign